all right
welcome back to Edna
I'd like to thank everybody for lasting
through yesterday's exact session and
getting all their committee reports in
on time I'm
representative leckis and groda both did
more than their share of motions
yesterday so
they're all in
okay I'm opening the hearing on House
Bill 518
and I don't see any of the sponsors
please
am I right
will downgrade the importance if they
can't figure out to show up
good morning colleagues uh for the
record Peter Schmidt representing award
one in Dover uh I'm pleased to open
house bill 518 establishing a commission
to study revisions to occupational
regulation of Pharmacists and pharmacies
I'm opening on behalf of Representative
Merchant who's not yet here and I will
hand in the pink card momentarily but
obviously I will take no questions
thanks
thank you thank you representative I
have no ping cards from anybody is there
anyone else who wishes to testify on
this
well that's uh discouraging
all right in that case I will close the
public hearing
and we're free until
10 30. I
should I go down and see if I can figure
because he may
yeah well that I mean we may reopen it
sometime because both he and roachford
have been cornering me in the hallway
well yeah but they don't if they don't
show it's a big problem
foreign
with the arrival of Representative
Merchant I'm going to open reopen the
public hearing on House Bill 518
thank you madam chair chairwoman my
apologies to the committee I also have
another bill I'm trying to introduce
downstairs at the same time and I should
have found somebody to backfill me I did
not so I apologize to the committee for
that error
house bill
we're trying to do here is the Border
Pharmacy
and they support the bill
is to try to take RSA 318
and look at the bill RSA collectively if
you will
in the world of Pharmacy we have the
business of Pharmacy we have the
practice of Pharmacy
by looking at a study committee
comprised of folks that have the
knowledge base
should we take 318 and separate the
Business from The Practice
so that's the intent of it it's a study
committee I have folks willing to serve
on the committee that's really the
intent of it it's nothing more than that
it's just get people together around the
table and talk about this with
stakeholders and saying is it time for
us
to the evolution of Pharmacy
take the business of Pharmacy and
separate it from the practice of
Pharmacy the pharmacist Practice
Pharmacy the owners operate the business
that's fundamentally what it's all about
thank you are there any questions
yeah thanks I I guess I'm usually
skeptical of these things
um because basically from the time it
passes you're gonna have maybe three
months maybe four uh before the
reporting deadlines I mean do you have
people lined up who are going to
actually meet and work on this
enough that it's going to do something
useful I guess in my question thank you
for the question represent Lucas people
have told me they're willing to serve on
it but you never know until you actually
hold the meeting two actually is going
to show up but I have the support of the
board I have support of people within
the profession to talk about this
um so my intent is to work on those
individuals that have shown the interest
yes
all right thank you reference favor
thank you madam chair thank you for
being here my question is when you I
understand that this is just just a bill
to establish a commission to study it
but when you say separate the business
from the practice can you elaborate on
that please especially when I hear that
the owners wouldn't be involved I
I'm not understanding thank you the
owners would be involved that would be
the
chain drug stores and so forth along
with Independence
um basically with how you run a pharmacy
now how you practice Pharmacy but how
you run the business
so therefore it's been completed it's
been co-mingled so as we evolve Pharmacy
more into a clinical role dealing with
patient care
I think it's important that we have an
RSA dealing with that growth of Pharmacy
not have it still Anchored In what I
call the business of Pharmacy which is
Mercantile
thank you madam chair give me a real
world example so you own the pharmacy
and I'm your pharmacist
and what is the reason for separating
can you give a real world example thank
you
good example of that is that I'll give
you more of analogy
in
medicine
the Physicians have their own RSA but
the hospitals also who run the business
have their own RSA facility management
they don't have them commingled together
so the Board of Medicine is responsible
for the practitioner
Department Health Human Services
responsible for how the hospitals run
but in Pharmacy because it evolved out
of the Mercantile business environment
a lot of the RSA is really
on how you run the business so give an
example we have how many hours you have
to have the pharmacy open that has
nothing to do with how you practice
Pharmacy it's a question how often the
hospital is open for instance so that
we're trying to do is is it time for us
to look at it globally
and say is it wise to break it apart or
is it just leave it alone and move on
with life and let it be what it is
thank you representative O'Brien
thank you um
with this committee I'm just looking
well as you hope in the future if this
passes and I look at different things
like good RX and different things where
uh I imagine most of the drugs come from
one or two uh Central Outlet uh but you
go to one Pharmacy there one price you
go to another Pharmacy they're another
price and then if you had the coupons
they're even possibly less would that be
within the scope of this try to look at
regulating the business better for the
consumer it's not trying to
create regulations not trying to create
law we're just trying to make the
Judgment call back to this legislative
body is it time to take the two
components which are weaved together
today and separate them in two separate
chapters within the RSA so one is going
to deal with representative O'Brien your
point that's the business how you price
things how I practice as a pharmacist
has nothing to do without the owner
wants to price the product
representative Dolan
thank you madam chair
I thank you representative
um my question is in the context of the
fact that we're the legislature is
drowning in committees and commissions
and this is going to be another one can
you give me the uh what you think the
life cycle of this commission would be
starting and finishing representative
Dolan the bond section two of the bill
repeals the commission effective
November 1st 2023. so this is a very
short-term limited spam study okay
thank you
anybody else
all right thank you very much
representative Merchant and thank you
for your Indulgence Madam chair
unfortunately you got here before the
next hearing was scheduled so we could
indulge you
any is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
all right I will close the hearing again
and uh
I don't think don't think this needs
subcommittee
okay swervin right there
Sure Stop
um
does it cost the taxpayers any money to
establish a commission
uh well there's the cost of processing
the paperwork and then there's mileage
for legislative members but it's
generally relatively cheap
the non-legislative members don't get
any reimbursement
it would have to be in other bills
um
next year
or they can just get together
and talk about it and do it without us
passing a bill too which has been known
to happen
okay
all right then
foreign
all right good morning
it uh
I'm opening the hearing on House Bill
532 I looks like representative Broda
wants to introduce the bill
I do thank you madam chair
House Bill 532
um
request the licensing the licensing and
for music therapists in New Hampshire
this bill is one that has come to you
before in this committee
and represents and there has been a
ongoing negotiations between the speech
therapists and music therapists
and I think we've come to an agreement
because I just spoke to the speech
therapist people and we have the music
therapist who will confirm this that
speech that music therapy does not treat
speech therapy
it treats people with speech therapy
speech disorders sorry let me say that
again speech therapy speech therapists
work with people who need who have
issues with speech communication
but um a music therapist doesn't treat
speech disorders but it works with
people who works with people who have
them and there's a collaboration between
the two
the amen there is going to be an
amendment to this bill which will help
clarify this
and I think that that will prepare the
bill for this committee to
understand finally and support the bill
I will not take any questions because I
know you've put a few people to testify
thank you uh thank you
may I ask a question Madam chair please
okay so representative Gorda did not
want to take questions but I believe
there's some kind of an amendment
we haven't seen it yet right
I'll submit it to OLS once we get it um
nailed down
okay
fine
in in that regard I will start out by
while we're waiting for the pink cards
to come around we'll I will mention that
this bill will be going to the licensing
subcommittee and
nothing will happen until that amendment
is available
[Music]
I just want the committee to know that I
work on the amendment today and I'll be
sure to get it to OLS by the end of the
day all right
Ashley just rosers
please turn your microphone on
and introduce yourself
if it's red is it okay hi my name is
Ashley durocher I'm from Rochester
um I'm an elected official City
councilor in Rochester so I'd also say
I'm supporting my constituents that have
um actually submitted comment to our
Council on this
um though there's not also many times
much we can do about it
um I'm also someone that's worked in the
Mental Health Human Services
domestic violence intervention and
research field for over 10 years
I'm also somebody that experiences
complex PTSD
I have experienced a trauma such as
domestic violence I also most recently
really started to understand that
responding to a public health pandemic
as a public health professional for 60
to 70 hours a week is really bad for
your brain and truly the only
um
real Comfort I have found in any of the
therapies that I have tried has been
music therapy music has been a part of
my life for as long as I can remember
it's one of the things I lean on most
um but the interesting thing about how
music therapy has helped me
is that
with complicated trauma such as complex
PTSD
there really isn't always a way to
express what you're feeling sometimes
you can't there aren't words it's not as
simple as talking it through at a talk
therapy session which I have done for
let's see I'm 32 today is my birthday
the past 20 years of my life
um so I actually in learning about this
piece of legislation I was actually
shocked
um that it's not already possible for
music therapists to Bill Insurance to
have licensure in this state in addition
to the fact that we are one of the last
in the country for access to mental
health treatment
we also have a serious issue with
keeping health care workers in our state
just recently nhpr was discussing the
housing crisis and the effect on the
mental health Workforce there is an
alliance in Dover called the Mental
Health Alliance they have also
identified this as a challenge in the
Dover Community where they've
experienced quite a bit of tragedy due
to Suicide loss so I would just press
you as somebody that is both a person in
recovery a person with you know a mental
illness that I have tried for years to
find help for and now have to pay out of
pocket for and can hardly afford it I
can't imagine how many other people
could benefit from this you know it's
it's one of those things that you're
able to express yourself and get things
out and have this thing in front of you
to say oh my gosh there's this beautiful
piece of music I'd also say that I
originally was connected with music and
art therapy through working with a
crisis program that I had needed After
experiencing domestic abuse
and every person I've talked to when I'm
trying to find care for my daughter
who's six has said you should go to the
sonatina center however you have to pay
out of pocket but it's worth every penny
nothing has worked this well so I just
say please support this bill for people
like me who are health care workers who
are mothers who are trying to be leaders
in their community and also experiencing
things that you probably would never
know
um it's one out of four people so people
sitting on this on this committee or
have some experience with mental illness
and substance use disorder
happy to take any questions
thank you and I appreciate your showing
up on your birthday
representative
thank you madam chair maybe this
question is better for my colleague
um
representative groda for
the is the reason for this bill to
license it in order for insurance is
that the sole reason that is always one
of the major reasons for any health care
profession is that many insurance
companies will only
allow licensed individuals to directly
bill
may I please sure um so there's also a
piece where you cannot apply to build
New Hampshire Medicaid so not only is it
private insurance companies it's also
State Medicaid so any family or
individual seeking these Services if
they happen to come across them
um we'll have to pay for them out of
pocket
um so it's just something really worth
noting and again the the access to
mental health treatment in in our state
is is really frustrating and this is
also a piece of our art and culture in
our state and I think those two things
really
um the fact that these can be addressed
together especially in our community in
Rochester we are really into our art and
our music I can just see how much more
this will benefit people if they can if
these providers can bill to it
um you know it would encourage more
people to to seek
um using this type of treatment to help
our communities
you know
thank you madam chair
so the intent is to be able to actually
bill out for the service which makes
sense but would you be opposed to having
no penalty provision for those that are
practicing without said license does it
really matter to have because I'm just
concerned well I'm sorry I'll answer
that question
so I'll be candid I don't know all this
the specifics around that I know that
there are other folks here um that have
been more involved in this process so I
can't answer that question but I would
definitely say that to my understanding
there are people that are licensed that
are not able to Bill and that's really
important to me unsure about the piece
with non-licensure
but you're receiving you receive sound
therapy right in music therapy right now
correct correct I'm an unlicensed
provider
it must be since we don't that's fine
right so yes so they're they're they're
certified they have credentials they go
through you know okay but but right now
it's not licensed it cannot they cannot
be licensed without a state licensure
system is the issue so follow my
follow-up my point being that you're
receiving the serviceman unlicensed
provider right now so your service would
not change with the stamp of approval so
being we could have something that's
unlicensed people could still be
unlicensed it would not affect
your treatment
correct I could still keep attending
treatment it's just it's the cost folks
for folks it's that cost piece it's you
know 80 to you know could be up to 150 a
session and for for families that's
especially in my area where we Face some
of the most
um intense
um you know costs of living and housing
um it's really just so inaccessible for
folks
thank you representative thank you um
maybe I misheard you human spoke but I
thought I heard you say that there are
people who are licensed who cannot get
reimbursed that may have been a mistake
on my part so I meant what I met was
thinking license was saying that like
they go through certifications they go
through schooling they you know they go
through that same process that and often
I believe like they have other you know
things they specialize in and this can
just be like another thing that they can
offer such as like if someone's doing
art therapy they can then now
incorporate music therapy as well but
again I'm not the expert on this I'm a
patient and there are
um therapists that are here today too
thank you thank you
thank you for so much for your testimony
uh you mentioned a session could cost
180 is that correct is that for an hour
is that for like is that just for the
individual is that yeah yeah that's just
for about an individual or an hour I'll
ultimately say that um I was going on a
scholarship through that I actually was
connected through uh to with the doorway
which is part of the um Continuum of
Care for substance use in New Hampshire
so um they're aware of it they know it
works
um and sorry I forgot your question no
you already answered it okay yeah great
representative O'Brien thank you madam
chair
thank you for taking my question you may
not be able to answer this and I'm glad
that the therapy is working out good for
you that's positive uh but I think the
committee would like to know what's
happening in other states New Hampshire
live free and die but however
to see if this program exists into
success as in other states I think that
would help us come to a conclusion on
this
so I can't answer that question
um I think that somebody else would yeah
I can't answer that question thank you I
was more putting it out there when
somebody comes up to speak and maybe
they'll be a better qualified but I
thank you for your attempt
okay
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you
I like to call Stephanie uh
renef
hi I'm Stephanie Rooney from Derry I
grew up in Salem
good morning Madam chair and good
morning Representatives I have been a
board certified music therapist since
2001. I graduated from Anna Maria
College which at the time there were
only three colleges in New England where
you could obtain a music therapy degree
after that degree program we have to
attend at that time it was over a
thousand forty hours unpaid
to receive our certification so when I
came back to New Hampshire I was so
excited to go into nursing homework
because I am also a dementia
practitioner when I came home in 2001
and I had been working at Shriners burn
Hospital working with the burn children
using music therapy I got to help them
with their pain I got to help them with
their schoolwork and I got to help them
die peacefully
and that is a huge burden especially as
a new professional but it was amazing to
have that experience as a new
professional that I could bring home to
the state of New Hampshire because while
in in the state of Texas I worked on
their task force to make sure that their
music therapists are licensed so that
they can be reimbursed for the amazing
services that they do and throughout my
career I was working for over 20 years I
came back to the state and I couldn't
get a job I had to move in 2002 all the
way to New Orleans to work at Children's
Hospital where there I was assigned to
the NICU I saw a babies born without
brains I saw their parents have to deal
with that
it was harsh especially as a mom
so I was there to be able to comfort
that mother and help that child as best
I could I also worked on the oncology
floor
I had one patient that only survived
three weeks
but what a miraculous opportunity I had
to provide that person
some music some comfort in their last
days of their lives
and if you don't mind I'd like to share
a little personally too
back in 2011 when I returned to the
state I was returning to New Hampshire
in hopes again for a full-time music
therapy job because I had held one for
10 years in the state of Texas I had
worked in schools assisted living senior
care everything that I could
and we moved back to New Hampshire
because my husband needed care in Boston
he was a paraplegic and he had become so
ill that he needed hospice
well I was so excited to be back in New
England with all of my former classmates
and all of my colleagues
but I couldn't get a job as a music
therapist to support our family when he
was unable to work
and when he needed hospice care I
couldn't find a hospice that had a music
therapist that could provide the
services to help him die comfortably
I wonder
with love for music
my
training and the training of the other
professionals if he would have had a
more peaceful death
if we had been able to provide him with
this service
so I'm so thankful for the person who
spoke before me because some of our
clients and some of our patients are
here today to tell you about how music
therapy has affected them
I can speak to what it's like to be a
professional
I can't speak to what it's like to have
received music therapy
but I can tell you how it would have
helped me say goodbye to my husband
during those days
thank you very much for listening to my
testimony I really hope you passed this
because it would mean it would mean that
many of us could support our families we
could be reimbursed through insurance
companies to be able to stay here in New
Hampshire unlike me who graduated in
2001 got certified and had to leave
so thank you for hearing me today I'm
open to any questions thank you very
much for representing Brody you can't
you've testified
all right
anyone else representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair so there was some
confusion at the beginning of the
hearing with regard to the question of
Licensing
and it got conflated in my view with uh
whether somebody is a certified or
trained professional
so is it not the case that that music
therapist
music therapy is a profession a
recognized profession which requires
training and training is provided in
Nationwide uh so other training in that
line other training facilities here in
New Hampshire or do you have to go to
Boston for example well currently there
are none and never have been any in New
Hampshire and one one program is closing
the Anna Maria College program that I
attended and was able to study with Dr
Lisa Summer one of the most renowned
music therapists is ending in 2025. so
it is it is unfortunately
we're losing we're losing strength
because not every state
has approved life licensure New York has
Texas has many other states I don't know
the exact number of states that have
approved the licensure but yes you're
correct we go through four years of
training people will speak more to this
as well and then we have to do our
internship under professionals just like
a social worker would have to when
they're going to get their licensure so
we do a lot of the same things but we
are not recognized with a license
which hampers our ability to help people
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking the question
can you tell me
what a music therapy session would
entail how
what happens during that time absolutely
it it's different for everyone because
what's so unique about what music
therapists do is that we're able to
First assess somebody like a social
worker a speech therapist a physical
therapist anybody who does an assessment
so we would have an assessment session
where we determine if someone would
benefit from music therapy services
because that's the other problem is that
if you're not a trained professional and
you're not a board-certified music
therapist how do you know if music would
be appropriate and what absolutely help
someone because there are times when
music could harm someone
and we don't want to harm anyone either
so that's why licensure is very
important to me as well so let's just
say that we've had an assessment and
let's say I'm working is there a
particular population you'd like to know
like in the schools in the hospitals we
work with we work in every Health Care
setting education
what would best help you let's say a
school-aged individual okay so School
we're we're trying to help them attain
some academic
aspect so let's say a child is possibly
echolalic so we have a child who has
autism so this person is just echoing
everything they hear echoing everything
they hear echoing everything they hear
so one of the things I might do as a
music therapist is ask them to have
three spontaneous words within a
30-minute session so instead of
repeating everything I'm saying I would
use a song like in the jungle
and where we have we would have possibly
some manipulatives to help this child so
I would be singing in the jungle and I
could say in the jungle the mighty
jungle the lion
and I wait for the child to tell me what
is the lion going to do in the jungle
and so we know how music affects the
brain we know how music is fun and so
there's so many other components of what
we do that truly reaches some children
that are considered unreachable does
that help
you're welcome
any yes representative Fitzpatrick
most certifications have a book of Book
of Knowledge
can you give some examples of what's
contained in your be okay
we have in each type of person we work
with we have uh I can't think of what
it's called please forgive me I also
have a um a debilitating disease that
causes some brain fog so I appreciate
your patience with me so we have
standards of practice and within those
standards of practice it tells us how we
can and work with and not work with
individuals so we have to do an
assessment we have certain regulations
under that and I know that these other
music therapists will be able to speak
to it better than I can at this time
so there's there's everything you could
imagine in that poke when when how long
our duration of services will be the
length uh the quality of the services
when termination needs to be done when a
referral needs to be given to another
music therapist or if if there is an
incident where they might benefit from
another therapy so yes it contains quite
everything that we would need to know
and in order for a university or College
to have a program they have to meet
these standards as well
follow up and so I would just uh I'm
making the Assumption and what you just
told me would be part of the contents of
the examination that yes we do we do
have an examination post hour training
to hold the title music therapist board
certified thank you
representative Lucas
um thank you so you mentioned that music
therapy could actually cause harm could
you offer some reasonably specific
examples of that well I can I can give
you two examples
um when someone is inactive dying
sometimes they can be extremely agitated
and at a point when somebody's extremely
agitated we might not want to bring
another stimulus like music into that
room and that would go for children as
well if they're if they're extremely
agitated because of a mental health
issue or again autism something like
that that would not be the most
opportune time to use music therapy
especially if you are new to the person
if you had a relationship a therapeutic
relationship with that person there's
ways that we know how we might be able
to reach them
thank you you're welcome
anyone else
yes representative Gerhard just real
quick thank you chairman
one of the letters of support that was
passed around just now
in the second paragraph
she writes because I'm not licensed with
the state of New Hampshire this is a
music therapy program provider in
Manchester
because I'm not licensed with the state
of New Hampshire I cannot provide the
justification for the therapy I am
providing as such families must take the
extra step of securing a note from a
different licensed professional to
justify Music Therapy Services while
this is a workaround for now it often
adds extra time to setting up music
therapy services for clients and it goes
on from there so I understand the
workarounds of pain but at the same time
the fiscal note associated with this
bill 60 something thousand dollars so I
just wonder basically the state would
then be taking up the burden of
administering these notes so I'm saying
if as as such the service could be
provided by one Central psychologist
providing notes to the music therapy
providers and then getting reimbursed
is that incorrect that is incorrect okay
we do how it would work very much like
physical therapists that say you or I go
to the doctor we get a referral and a
written prescription for that physical
therapy at this time we it's very
difficult for anyone to get that written
notice from
a healthcare provider that you need
music therapy so that that's one of the
burdens that we're facing so right now
instead of getting it directly from from
the from the physician per se now the
family has to go back I can't I can't as
a professional can't call that person
again now the family who wants the
service has to go back and ask for that
prescription so to speak to be written
appreciate
so would you say that some of these
other professionals don't believe in
music therapy because they're not
issuing these notes for referral I don't
think that they don't believe in I think
they actually use a lot of music I just
don't think that they are as aware of
they could be of our services and that's
part of why we would like to become
licensed just to have the opportunity to
teach them more and to help them further
help their
clients
thank you representative Lucas thank you
I mean if
sure let me offer a clarification the
licensing is paid for by the license
fees yes paid by the licensees so the
music therapist would be paying for it
thank you yes thank you for the
clarification any other questions uh yes
representative Gould
so for those families who
um
are struggling and cannot afford the
full
pocket
how many can you afford to service for
free or reduced rates how many families
would you estimate get turned away from
music therapy I honestly can't can't
answer that I can tell you when I was
working for assisted living facilities I
was and when I was doing groups I would
offer a sliding scale but of course that
at the end of the day that harms what
I'm taking home
and what I'm able to do I I would love
to have service everyone for free I'm
sure like any doctor would we love to
give this service away for free we're
passionate about what we do but
um I I don't know the exact numbers and
I'm sure that many of these other
therapists might have a more accurate
answer to that thank you
you're welcome
all right seeing no more questions thank
you for your testimony thank you Rebecca
gildeer
hello Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Rebecca gilday I'm
a board certified music therapist and I
am representing the music therapy task
force for New Hampshire thank you for
the opportunity to speak with you in
support of the bill uh 532 relative to
licensure and regulation of Music
therapists
there are currently 48 music therapists
working in the state of New Hampshire in
settings such as early intervention
special education day programs Memory
Care Behavioral Health units eating
disorder clinics and substance use
programs just to name a few
music therapists are uniquely trained
and nationally board certified to work
with clients and domains such as
attention and cognition attachment
socialization emotional processing and
expression excessive expressive and
receptive communication and mobility and
physical rehabilitation this answers
your question sir
music therapists are evidence-based prac
use evidence-based practices to work
toward each client-centered goal
supported through a body of research
spanning decades you may see your local
music therapists working with a child
with autism to develop expressive
communication through techniques such as
call and response singing or to motivate
the child to finish a phrase in a
favorite song
like our friend already said
another music therapist may be working
with a patient undergoing chemotherapy
using music to decrease their perception
of pain
also researched and known
or you may see me working with adults in
recovery using the songwriting process
as a means to process their experiences
name their motivations for recovery and
identify their strengths and resilience
in a group of women
working through their
um through their recovery they've
written a song with a lyrics
of these
I've constructed These Bricks as a wall
of protection shielding Who I Am from
the world I sit in the uncomfortable
dismantling my resistance to let the
light come shining through
the education training and certification
of a music therapist is expansive and
rigorous a music therapist must earn a
bachelor's degree or higher with a
curriculum that includes music human
development psychology anatomy and
physiology and Behavioral Sciences
through this diverse course of study a
student learns how to use the elements
of Music the relationship between the
therapist and the client and the act of
musicing itself as a means of meeting
smart meaning specific measurable
appropriate relevant and timely goals
for their clients in cognition
socialization communication motor
movement or emotional expression
in addition to their classes a student
practices therapeutic skills and
practicum sites and ultimately through
an internship at an approved mental
health special education or Healthcare
facility all of which totals a minimum
of 1200 hours in supervised clinical
training
at the completion of their academic and
clinical training students are eligible
to take the national examination
administered by the certification board
for music therapists which is an
independent non-profit certifying agency
accredited by the national commission
for certifying agencies
after a successful completion of that
exam graduates are issued the credential
necessary for professional practice
music therapist board certified or the
initials mtbc
to demonstrate continued competence and
maintain this credential music
therapists are required to complete 100
hours of continuing music therapy
education every five years these
educational standards are comparable to
the standards of other Allied
professions such as occupational therapy
and speech therapy all of which require
licenses in the state which is why is it
is which is part of the reason why it's
essential to licensed music therapy in
New Hampshire in the last 12 years 11
states have established a music therapy
license and 15 additional states have
introduced licensure bills New Hampshire
is one of them in 2023
a state license from music therapy
Alliance New Hampshire with the active
movements across the country recognizing
and validating the music therapy
profession with other Allied professions
although board certified music
therapists know the depth of their
clinical training their standards of
practice code of ethics and scope of
practice the general public often does
not a music therapist is not only
equipped to use music therapeutically in
various settings but is also able to
respond to the emotional response or
trigger that may emerge as a result of
the therapeutic process
they can address the various needs that
are present in the session or within the
family and share observable progress
toward goal areas music therapists are
also evaluating when music therapy is no
longer needed or even detrimental to the
individual and have a clinical process
for termination or referral out for
additional resources
part of the need for licensure music
therapists in the state of New Hampshire
is increasing access and preventing harm
in music therapy can occur when a
non-board certified musicians or helpers
use music in the physical cognitive or
use music to the physical cognitive or
emotional detriment of a client because
they do not share the educational
background or clinical skills described
above
here are some examples
because of music's effect on heart rate
and respiration a non-music therapist
could disrupt the vital signs of
premature premature infants in a NICU
causing dangerously low heart rates
breathing rates and decreased
non-nutritive sucking and detrimental
overstimulation
or they could adversely affect the heart
rate and oxygen saturation levels in a
medically fragile patients
a client with complex PTSD could be
triggered by a song a hospital musician
plays leaving the client experiencing an
aspect of their trauma with no Aid in
regulating reorienting or grounding
when music is used in dementia care
music can both regulate or agitate the
client
when dementia clients become agitated
the risk of injury is heightened an
unqualified provider may use
contraindicated music not respond
appropriately in the moment or increase
agitation resulting in injury
another provider using music in a
classroom may bring instruments to
students who need extra behavioral
support and without proper assessment of
the client's needs result in instruments
thrown at the musicians students or
teachers
board certified music therapists have a
rigorous and substantial training to
address each of these concerns however
without licensure in the state there is
no oversight into who is working with
these clients in these scenarios with
licensure the public can reach a
qualified music therapist and know that
the risk of harm will be significantly
reduced to feel safe with the standards
of and ethical practice being upheld by
a governing body
for more information I'm attaching a
fact sheet outlining examples of harm
Within the Music Therapy practice
licensure for music therapists will also
increase access to the effective and
evidence-based treatment currently
residents of New Hampshire must pay out
of pocket apply for grant funding or
apply for scholarships to receive
services this process is not only
discriminatory against those with fewer
resources it also frequently reduces the
amount of therapy sessions a client can
have hindering the positive effects of
treatment
with licensure music therapists would be
able to panel with insurance companies
and Medicaid increasing access to New
Hampshire residents for whom music
therapy would be clinically appropriate
and effective
at our practice alone with seven music
therapists on staff in 2022 we served
141 individual clients at the center and
over 3 000 clients in facilities like
schools short-term Behavioral Health
Memory Care units and substance use
programs this is the impact of just
seven of the 48 music therapists in the
state consider the impact of those
already receiving services and how many
more would be able to access it with
less barriers
by creating a state license for music
therapists you will be the governing
body that upholds the music therapy's
high standards of practice thereby
protecting your constituents from harm
and non-certified practitioners that do
not have this body of experience in
education in addition you will be
creating a state standard that is
comprehensive and accessible to the
public ensuring a transparent process
for the New Hampshire citizens to find a
qualified and licensed music therapy
provider and creating an access point
for those unable to afford effective
Services out of pocket to use their
health care for music therapy services
today I share my support of Bill 532 and
ask you to vote Yes for a license in New
Hampshire
thank you could you uh leave us your
written testimony happy to thank you
are there any other questions
representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair so in your
testimony you alluded to something that
has come up previously in this hearing
namely that music could cause harm in
the hands of somebody who's incompetent
or untrained is it not the case that
harm can come to people who encounter
doctors nurses
um teachers you name the profession if
they are unqualified untrained
incompetent mentally ill or whatever
just as is is the possibility in the
hands of untrained people using music
therapy
yes so just like any provider in the
state there's always a risk for harm and
that's what liability insurance is for
however at current in our current system
there's no
constituents have no way to say that
this is a licensed profession the way
that they can search out for doctors and
nurses they know that there is a
standard of practice that's upheld by
the state
um so right now people can walk around
and say I'm a music therapist and unless
the unless the client knows to ask for
their credentials they have no way of
knowing whether or not that person is
board certified whether or not that
person is
um able to provide the service that
they're saying that they're able to
provide
follow up follow up
but it's it's not the case that uh
somebody who's a musician
who would uh play his or her instrument
um and think that that might be
beneficial uh
would be capable of doing harm to
someone just as somebody who thinks
they're a doctor or have medical skills
or whatever
it the training that you alluded to is
the underlying
guarantor if you will that's the a
person has some kind of competence
precisely and if you've noticed I'm sure
that you are all on the internet in some
kind of way people love to use the
phrase this like some blank fill in the
blank is my therapy and a lot of times
people use creative arts as their
therapy and creative arts are
therapeutic there's so many good things
about that expression however it's very
easy for a musician to come in and be
like yes like music is therapeutic I'm
definitely music therapy but they have
no training or clinical practice the way
that music therapists who are board
certified do and that's the big
difference
thank you thank you other questions
representative
um yeah so you said that uh people would
know to check and see if they're
licensed but they might not know to ask
about certification I don't know see
that I don't know that I see the
difference couldn't they
you know maybe get the word out that
people can ask for certification if
that's something they they are proof of
certification if that's something they
care about rather than dealing with this
with licensing I understand the payment
issue but on that point if you could
comment
if people want to ask for credentials
they're going to ask for credentials
that's your point
I mean whether it's asking for licensing
or asking for if they have some
certification sure so there's definitely
the part of like educating the public
about what we do and what our
qualifications are however I think it is
the duty of the state to protect its
constituents and by licensing that's
what that does
thank you other representative
representative Simon thank you madam
chair
um
so
just a question as far as this question
about doing harm is concerned music is a
pretty universally used thing it's loved
by all of us we all listen to it we all
use it
um when you're talking about somebody
who's practicing without proper
certification and if we were obviously
to give you licensure and the ability to
separate people who are licensed from
people who are not
um where does the where's the boundary
line in that as far as people using
music would music have to be the primary
thing
um that an unlicensed person would be
using in their therapy sessions or for
example if somebody just happened to be
using music while doing some other form
of therapy would there be accountability
for me it's just kind of it's a little
cloudy at the moment New Concept for me
granted but where that line gets drawn
so the land gets drawn at the definition
of music therapy so people so for
example let's say a talk therapist is is
using music in their session to explore
something with their client that client
that therapist isn't saying that they're
doing music therapy in that moment
they're using music in
um they're already licensed profession
uh the line comes when
unqualified I guess
unqualified people are using
you okay hang on let me restart I'm glad
no I'm glad it wasn't an easy thing to
answer because I'm a little confused
myself yeah so
let me start with the definition of
music therapy the definition of music
therapy is using music to address
non-musical goals so using music to
promote cognition promote
um expressive and receptive
communication to develop physical motor
movements right so the music itself is
the facilitating factor of that growth
for that person so music therapists are
the ones who know how the music affects
that growth in that specific area
so it doesn't say that people can't use
music in different therapeutic
environments that's not what we're
saying but we're saying the body of
knowledge of knowing how music affects
those growth areas is specialized and is
important to identify
um so that's the difference is knowing
how the music affects that specific area
of growth for that person or that goal
area for that person
quick follow-up
um so just as by way of example and once
again if it's it's fine if you aren't
comfortable with the question
um
a psychologist is meeting with a patient
turns on some music in the background
that the psychologist feels like will be
soothing and then the client complains
that the music actually was harmful in
some way
um obviously if you're licensed you
would then have an oversight Board of
some sort
um would that be a lit from your
perspective would that be a legitimate
complaint would the board have something
to say about that or not because it's
not technically a music therapist that's
doing the work
the board have something to say about
that
um only if they're like only if they're
saying that they're doing music therapy
in their session and they don't have the
music therapy licensure we're not
cornering the market on using music
therapeutically music can be used
therapeutically in a lot of different
settings just like many other techniques
are used across many Allied professions
um no one's cornering the market on on
the use of music but we are trying to
specify the language of what music
therapy is and so that people understand
what they are what they are getting and
when they're getting it yeah thank you
so much appreciate it
representative true
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question ma'am
um
I believe you said that you uh in a
facility that was seven other
or seven music therapists yes
how do you you get paid
not from insurance companies correct
it's all private pay so people can
either pay out of pocket sometimes we
partner with different facilities to
offer scholarships for services we have
a sliding scale fee based on income and
we also help clients in certain
facilities who qualify to apply for
grant funding
follow up thank you madam chair
um
so if a person were
referred by a a doctor a physician or a
psychiatrist or a psychologist
to receive music therapy
would that qualify for insurance no
because we're not licensed so insurance
companies give a blanket statement that
unless you can provide a license number
they will not engage with you and the
same goes for Medicaid
thank you
yes thank you representative Gerhard
thank you madam chair are you familiar
do you with the NH music therapy task
force correct okay so on the one flyer
talking about Education and Training
says bachelor's degree or higher
required and 1200 Plus hours on-site
clinical training internship is this the
current requirements to be board
certified correct
so
a follow-up
wouldn't such stringent standards
decrease the availability of care for
people that they have to meet these my
point being is if music therapy is is
good for as many people as we can get to
it there's going to be different sliding
scales of people that are capable and
what they can do with it so I'm just
wondering
is this High bar necessary to get these
Services out to people who need them yes
so
we to be working therapeutically with
clients you have to have
at minimum a bachelor's education in
each of those areas I outlined in human
development in cognition to understand
that the frequency of so like one of the
one of the really interesting things is
how music affects the brain and our
respiratory system so the pace and the
frequency of the music affects our heart
rate affects our perspiration affects
our breathing pattern and a high school
graduate does not know that like a high
school graduate does not uh
I do thank you madam chair
and thank you for taking my question my
question has to do with um the
scholarships you mentioned and the
sliding scale so as a businesswoman
um
can you tell us like is there a limit to
the number of scholarships and sliding
scales or can you service all
um families who request the service but
but don't have the out-of-pocket money
to pay for it
are you essentially asking are people
turned away because they cannot pay
um okay so we do as for our and I'll let
Marissa is going to testify later she's
our business owner and she'll be able to
answer this much more thoroughly however
I'll say that we do our everything in
our power to not turn away clients
however there are a number of clients
who have stopped Services because they
have become unaffordable so we do
everything we can however we do believe
because it's a part of Health Care that
it should be covered by Health Care
absolutely yes insurance is not Health
Care by the way
yes okay thank you anyone else
representative thank you um just wanted
to mention uh for you and everyone that
this is going to subcommittee I was
wondering if you could be available
um you know to to help with that as well
sure all right thank you
thank you very much for Testimony
Michael King
foreign
good morning honorable Representatives
my name is Michael King and I'm a
disabled Vietnam veteran
I'm here today to ask you to vote in
favor of music therapy
licensure bill
as you know veterans face many
challenges excuse me
upon their challenges Upon returning
home and lots of different types of
therapy are offered
but one of the most powerful therapies
isn't available to most veterans because
without licensure the insurance
companies won't cover it and most people
including myself can afford to pay out
of pocket
I have always had a strong connection to
music and my daughters who are both
musicians would sing some carefully
chosen songs at the veterans ceremonies
most times everyone was in tears because
they were sharing the common emotion
that came through the music
it bonded these people together and
helped them to express some very
powerful emotions they probably wouldn't
be able to express otherwise and that
was just from two girls singing
patriotic songs
the Patriotic music the practice of
music therapy is much more intentional
in its evaluation and treatment when
working with clients I think we all
allow the transformational power of
music
and the benefits of music therapy should
be available to everyone so please vote
in favor of licensure for music therapy
thank you
thank you Mr King are there questions
all right seeing none thanks
thank you very much
Marissa Scott
good morning Madam chairwoman and
members of the committee I want to keep
this very brief for you I know you've
heard a lot of testimony today
um I am a board certified music
therapist and I support HB 532 I am also
a business owner as has been mentioned
and we serve about 3 000 individuals in
New Hampshire per year
um the piece that I really want to drive
home today is
um that I know you keep hearing about is
really the insurance piece and as a
business owner I turn people away
um not necessarily turning people away
but um
I answer the question no we do not
accept your insurance
you know 20 to 40 times a month
um and I'm constantly telling people I'm
really sorry here are some other options
and I've done everything that I can to
help people get more access to services
like we have a sliding fee and we have a
scholarship program we've partnered with
our local hospital who provides some
Services I get just somebody had
mentioned earlier about doctor referrals
I get from Dover Pediatrics referrals
from Dover Pediatrics come in probably
like
you know 10 to 15 referrals from the
doctors for their plate patients because
they're hoping that this referral and
can be used for us and we people can try
to get out of network
you know reimbursement for services
because we have to be out of network
providers but they can't
um there's very limited success most
people don't have a lot of outer Network
benefits so
um I've included for you today a direct
email conversation between myself and a
provider enrollment specialist with
Medicaid directly denying my provider
application
um due to lack of licensure I hear the
same thing from private insurance
companies so we can't tell these
families you can have Services
um and that really takes away from their
independent Choice people should be able
to choose their doctor they should be
able to choose their therapist they
should be able to choose what type of
um you know what type of school they
want to go to
um it everybody is a little bit
different we all have different
preferences and the right uh you know
there's no one therapy that's the right
fit for every single person in New
Hampshire and right now this licensure
not being able it's just a barrier they
can't it's not even an option for people
who are you know utilizing Medicaid it's
not it's not an option for them so they
don't have that choice and by removing
this it doesn't make you the governing
board of you know whether or not
Medicaid is going to reimburse or not
that's still
that's going to be based on medical
necessity but it removes the barrier so
that they at least have the option to be
assessed to see if it is medically
necessary because right now that's not
an option so I urge you to vote in
support of this
um bill
and I'll take questions
thank you I think we've exhausted our
questions on the previous testifier
thank you
just one question Madam chair yes
representative Schmidt can you be
available for the subcommittee that
representative
Becca says referred to yes I can thank
you excellent thank you
all right does anyone else wish to
testify on House Bill 532
okay seeing none I will close public
hearing it is going to subcommittee
which will be scheduled at a later date
and I'm opening the public hearing on
House Bill 507 and call Representative
representative Santo nastasa
okay
take a break
at least you want the government
approval and somebody else to pay for
not clear which is
that not clearly just a stronger
foreign
okay uh thank you ma'am chair and
members of the committee representative
Santa nastasso representing Rindge
Jaffrey in Dublin
uh so I'm going to be introducing House
Bill uh 507 uh this bill removes the
penalty for operating without an
occupational license as long as they do
not hold themselves out to be licensed
by the state
uh so this kind of change would make our
licensing uh voluntary instead of
compulsory and this kind of regime is uh
better for this uh it's a better policy
to make licensing uh better serve Public
Safety
um and and this is true because when you
have anything compulsory uh like
compulsory licensing it creates this uh
us for stem sort of mentality where
people are just gradually getting this
license because the state just mandates
it so and that's that's come becomes the
culture in the in the attitude towards
these licenses is that we're just doing
this because you know the state makes us
do it but uh it's not particularly uh
beneficial for Public Safety or even or
if there's even a point for it
um involuntary licensing regimes uh the
licensees and people who could
potentially get licensed are going to be
more likely to follow the guidelines and
actually consider uh the cultural safety
that uh the licensing regimes uh
therefore
um
all right
so and yeah government has a tendency to
kind of fight the last war so a lot of
times when they make rules and it's for
things that have already happened and
not uh forward-looking things that could
be going on right now that are unsafe
uh so just a couple of antidotes just uh
I have I just have a lot of licenses I'm
a truck driver I'm used to be EMT I've
got licenses all sorts of different
things uh but I have a couple of
examples where these two same industry
same people in it
um helicopter uh flight instructor
certified by the FAA
and it's totally clear in the general
aviation world uh that is just contempt
for the FAA nobody reports anything to
the FAA violations of the fars Federal
Aviation regulations go completely
unreported
um
you all the time you see things unsafe
going on nobody brings it up you know
maybe in private to the uh the pilot but
uh they don't No One's Gonna report to
the FAA uh on December 1st 1974 uh trans
World Airlines flight 514 uh crashed
into a mountain uh all 92 people aboard
were killed
um and the accident was caused by a
misunderstanding between uh air traffic
control and the pilots so the pilots
thought they were on
um they were being radar vectored when
in fact they were not uh and what was
interesting about this crash is the same
accent almost happened six weeks prior
and everybody knew about this problem
except the FAA uh and then after the
accident they implemented a system
called the NASA uh Reporting System
where Pilots can uh mechanics to and
everybody can send a form to NASA where
NASA will actually tear the name off
uh and then send that to the fa so they
could get some information of the field
to this to the FAA uh and even that
doesn't work nobody no one uses it uh
even with the incentives built in so if
you fill out a NASA form and then later
you're being investigated for what you
filled it out for uh they'll actually
it's like a get out of jail free card
but no one fills out because they don't
trust the FAA
and I just want to contrast this to uh
sport parachuting so a lot of the same
people are involved in sport parachuting
I'm a
United States parachute Association B
license holder uh but skydiving is
unregulated by the federal government uh
so instead USPA popped up it's a private
uh voluntary licensing regime that
issues four levels of licenses uh levels
a b and c and d and endorsements like
coach instructor uh tandem jumper stuff
like this so USPA produces the basic
safety rules uh they you know every year
they they publish it and
um
where I've never seen anyone's pickup
truck with an FAA sticker on the back of
it you know people love the USPA they
follow and respect the rules
um it's active with the members it gets
immediate input to what's happening in
the field so they're forward-looking
they can make changes to the basic
safety rules for accidents that haven't
already happened
um and they do all sorts of things like
published magazine and uh they're just
more connected with the members uh
so most Drop Zones are regulated by USP
but some are not but the licensees of
USPA if they jump on those none
regulated Drop Zones they still will
follow the basic safety rules because
they need to maintain their license uh
so with voluntary licensing uh the truth
is in New Hampshire right now there's
people that are practicing these
licensed professions unlicensed uh and
they're going to continue to do so
whether it's compulsory or not but uh
this kind of voluntary system is going
to be uh it's going to be better to
serve needs of the public
um so with that I'll take any questions
thank you
Gerhart yeah
thank you madam chair uh I do have a
couple
uh do you see any bleed over from this
now you mentioned in your examples the
FAA parachute jumping and uh everything
else like that but one of the licensed
things that's out there is let's pick
something that's practical everybody has
to call one and that's electrician he
meets a license standard he is liable if
the house catches fire because of that
actually he works off a book that is
supported by the national uh National
Fire Protection Association that's who
writes the fire code so to bleed over
from what your bill is doing could
affect let's say a licensed electrician
coming in and working on a job is that
correct uh that's correct uh so a
licensed electrician uh
the insurance companies typically almost
universally will require that the work
is done to code and it's done by a
licensed electrician so what
the thing is there's already unlicensed
electricians working on buildings all
the time it's very common making it this
will not change
whether or not you need a licensed
electrician to meet insurance
requirements unless it becomes the case
where that the state is inadequate in
providing safety and a private uh
electrician licensing regime came up and
then the insurance may switch to that or
something like this so this will you
know give uh the State Licensing regime
some Market competition that way
follow-up
are you aware
that New Hampshire falls uh the
unwritten rule a man's home is his
castle
so you are right that the homeowner
himself
yeah but only if he lives in a single
family home because what he does in the
duplex can jeopardize the adjacent
family that lives next door to him but
in the single family resident the
homeowner himself can do his own
electrical work but that does not
ah
he's not graced with any not filing a
bro a building permit to which
electrician would come down and
electrical you know inspector come down
to make sure that the work is safe and
everything else like that so in a way
are you aware that you know if you owned
your own property it you are allowed to
do that so it does exist in the state
uh I I guess maybe I didn't articulate
it well uh
I'm saying that there is unlicensed
electricians that work
out without following the it's not
illegal there's still work on
multi-family buildings and things like
this
follow-up thank you you say an
independent none under on uh under the
grace of a mass electrician's license uh
that's correct
okay thank you
represent Gerhart
thank you madam chair
foreign
experience I thought the one of the most
interesting things about the licensing
regime as it goes so far as construction
goes being a carpenter myself you can
build a house without a license
but you can't put the Electrical
Plumbing or in New Hampshire even
landscapers have to get licenses whereas
even Massachusetts I was looking at this
I saw it was interesting Massachusetts
Rhode Island and Connecticut do not need
license for
commercial residential I mean I'm sorry
that's for the commercial landscaping
license but that's besides the point I
was going to get it get at is the
contractors I feel would not hire
somebody that's incompetent because it
falls on their insurance their bond so I
have a million dollar Bond if I was
going to build something I do not feel I
would hire somebody that's a sketch ball
because it falls on me I just wonder if
there's a lot of other safeguards in
place such as just Market forces besides
the insurance aspect that would keep
this from current do you agree
uh yeah of course I agree with that but
insurance is a big deal I mean if your
building burns down and then they do an
inspection and they find out that the
wiring was done
incorrectly it wasn't to code uh and
it's required in your insurance that you
would have it done to code and have it
done by a licensed electrician then it's
not going to pay out so
with this change the the licensed
electricians are likely to stay the same
people will still want to get licensed
by the state it gives them credibility
uh and it and it helps them mandate
their insurance it's just taking away
the penalty for doing the work
unlicensed
to draft this legislation thank you I
was asked to put this Mill in by members
of the public
thank you
thank you madam chair
um
speaking to Insurance
we all know that it's important if you
have someone doing construction work
particularly at your home it's important
to see if they have insurance so that in
case the person performing the work is
injured at your home they are covered
how would this affect that do you not
have to have a license in order to
insure yourself if you're doing work in
those instances
uh yeah I believe it's correct that
insurance mostly would require you to be
licensed in order to do work and get and
get bonds and and things like this uh so
the licensing would still be there
exactly the same way as it is right now
and those contractors would get licensed
I expect with this change the same
amount of con the same it wouldn't
change the distribution of unlicensed
workers and licensed workers
follow up thank you madam chair but uh
if in fact you hire someone to do work
at your home without taking the step to
ask if they have that kind of insurance
then if someone is injured doing that
work that would fall to the homeowner to
cover that I would be liable to suit I
would yes and I think we're
getting very speculative
so yes the homeowner would would be
required to have insurance to cover
workers in their house
that's thank you
anybody else representative goalie
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
I see a lot of discussion going on about
Plumbing electrical and all that but
would this not also cover medical Fields
such as nurse practitioners doctors I
could say I'm a doctor or a pharmacist
and as long as I don't say I'm licensed
I can say I can go and practice medicine
uh yes that would be correct you would
be able to uh privately but just like
with the electricians and stuff like
this uh hospitals and insurance it's not
gonna pay out you know and Hospital's
not gonna staff people if unless the
hospital you know in some other world
didn't want licensed professionals uh
they're still going to require that
insurance is going to require it to pay
out I mean we just had the music therapy
bill with
that's unlicensed and people are doing
it and they're asking for license to
fulfill insurance requirements uh so but
yeah it would affect all those fields uh
are you conflicting are you are you um
misinterpreting or misunderstanding the
difference between unlicensed and
certified
uh no I I don't believe so could you
elaborate
yes
a license thank you sorry follow up
that's right you can't grant me the
follow-up
um the um
so you're saying that not only if
someone is so basically you're saying
anyone can do anything as long as they
are not
as long as they tell people they're not
licensed
and you don't mention the word certified
so people don't have to say can say that
they're unlicensed to be a doctor but
they can't say they don't have to say
that they're not only non-licensed
they're uncertified to be a doctor oh I
understand uh what you're asking
um so
the state would yeah the bill just says
they can't hold themselves out to to say
that they're licensed by the state so if
they're certified uh or not certified
the bill doesn't doesn't talk about that
thank you
all right thank you representative thank
you
Lindsay Kourtney
good morning
um Madam chair members of the committee
for the record Lindsey Courtney I'm the
executive director of The Office of
professional life insurance
certification
we have approximately it's always
subject to change about 240 license
types within the office
and I do think there is always an
opportunity for the general court to to
determine whether or not licensure is
truly necessary to protect the public
but one thing that I think is absolutely
certain is that
the nature of voluntary licensure really
contraves the whole purpose of licensure
which is to protect the public that is
the legislature has at some point made a
determination that we shouldn't allow
people to essentially consent to utilize
Services by an individual certain
Services by an individual who is not
licensed
and I can tell you why that's important
at least with certain fields
if you are not a trained physician for
example you are not going to know how to
accurately convey the risks and the
benefits uh to somebody that would
effectively be informed consent who
would utilize those services
additionally we have had issues where
it's not clear where people have crossed
the lines unlicensed practice typically
occurs when somebody who or at least
that we find somebody who is licensed
but yet they are practicing beyond the
scope of their license for example a
licensed nursing assistant we've talked
about this with the med spa bill
but they've we've had several issues
where lnas have held themselves out as
lnas which they are but have gone on to
administer botox for example which is
outside the scope of their practice
so that is considered unlicensed
practice but under those circumstances
the LNA would not necessarily know
that's outside the scope of their
practice so what are we to do in those
circumstances
I think
I think the bill really complains the
issue of whether or not we should
require licensure for certain Professor
professions versus whether or not
licensure should be voluntary in nature
or is necessary to protect the public
and I would submit the general court can
certainly look at that issue but
voluntary licensure really just defeats
the purpose of licensure in general with
that I'd be happy to answer any
questions
thank you are there questions
Gerhart thank you madam chair
as far as freedom of Association goes do
two people in your mind have the
opportunity to engage in a business
transaction outside the realm of the
state like for instance if somebody
wants to say to me I can do a surgeon on
my finger do you feel that that's
provided they have capacity but you have
to understand that certain laws are
intended to protect people who don't
have capacity such as children or El you
know people who are who are who lack
mental capacity
um and the example earlier regarding the
electrical work
um
people do hire unlicensed electricians
quite frequently because it is cheaper
most frequently it's undocumented
workers who will Who are accepting work
at a lower rate that's not within the
union rate
um and so
um but they may or may not have the
appropriate skills so as a building
owner certainly with capacity you could
contract and say I'm willing to accept
the risks and the benefits but what
about the child who's living in the unit
in that building they don't have
capacity and I think that that's what
these laws are intended to address
hello follow up please um
I understand you're saying but in my
mind the simple fact that people are
willing to go out and skirt the rules in
order to save money means that this
service that's not being provided at an
adequate price so I wonder if we're
really saving children as you say in the
in the grand scheme of things but that
just makes turn
yeah I mean I could I can't share cases
but we've had issues with
um shoddy electrical work for example
where where people have been injured
yes thank you very much thank you for
your time
foreign
thank you director for taking my
question uh besides being licensed but
this ensures that quality work if the
person is working within the
capabilities of his license and it has
value to the structure that the person
is working on in the case of the
electrician so going in the future the
house will be able to be free and clear
as sales and other obligations everybody
gets their home inspected before they
sell it so
yeah eliminating license could
jeopardize futuristic future homeowners
yes that's true licensure is intended to
ensure somebody has satisfied the bare
minimum requirements in order to protect
the public
representative Gould
can you tell me if this applies to a
homeowner doing their own work no not
for electrical there is a statutory
exemption to that
representative issue it
thank you madam chair
um director Courtney the reason that
most licensed practitioners of any field
whether it be construction or medical
charge more because they have invested
time and money to achieve that level is
that not true
I think that's beyond my scope of
expertise I think that's true as a
licensed attorney
um you know certainly I paid a lot of
money to get my degree and we would
expect to charge more than somebody who
didn't go to law school but that you
know I can't say that's true for other
professionals
thank you for your time okay very good
Sarah Holland
good afternoon thank you madam chair and
committee members my name is Sarah
Holland I am a licensed real estate
broker and I'm here on behalf of the New
Hampshire Association of Realtors in the
capacity of Vice chair of their public
policy committee
um as executive director Courtney
mentioned and affirmed licensure is to
protect the consumer
um when we get licensed as a real estate
licensee we do bare minimum education so
we all have a baseline of info in order
to protect the public
each year we spend countless hours to
educate ourselves on the numerous
changes and laws and regulations and
these include local Municipal changes
state changes regulatory changes in
different professions that we tend to
touch throughout a real estate
transaction as well as Federal changes
and this is to ensure that we guide our
clients through the purchase purchase
and sales process without harm and this
is harm that they may otherwise enter
simply by being unaware if they did not
have us as licensees to guide them
through that process yes there are
exceptions in statute now for property
owners to buy and sell their own
property but if anyone is to assist them
and to be financially compensated for
that work then they do need to have a
license
so some of those numerous laws and
regulations have to do with septic sewer
escrow landlord tenant laws mandated
disclosures and notifications agency and
more importantly fair housing which any
basic slip up that we may have as humans
in the process of engaging a buyer who
may be interested in purchasing a home
that we are selling has violations and
fines of up to one hundred thousand
dollars per offense an hour job and I'm
also a licensed educator relative to
real estate pre-licensing and we spend
three entire classes talking about fair
housing for our pre-license students so
all of these laws and regulations are
incredibly important and they are there
to protect the consumer
if we as licensees are being held
accountable to know this information and
to guide our clients appropriately
stripping the ability to hold those
accountable who are not licensed and
hold those themselves out as
practitioners who are just not licensed
and can do this work contradicts is a
contradiction to consumer protection
happy to take questions thank you very
much are there questions
I don't see any very good
Ian Underwood
thank you
to better turn your mic on and introduce
yourself
okay awesome my name is Ian Underwood I
live in Croydon uh thank you for
allowing me to testify I quickly want to
bring up three things that have been
raised the first is the idea that uh you
can't have a license that isn't required
I think a lot of you have one a PRL
license this is a license it's called a
license it is completely not mandatory I
don't have to get one of these to carry
a gun I don't have to get one of these
to do anything but I can get one
because it might make some people feel
better about dealing with me in some
situations which is so a voluntary
license is already a thing
in New Hampshire
the second thing is
um
this idea that just because somebody has
a license that he is somehow
capable or competent and there's a three
word answer to that which is public
school teachers
they're licensed they're certified we
have 40 literacy in our schools so the
the idea that you have a license
guarantees something I think is just a
demonstrable fallacy the third thing is
it's interesting to notice if you look
at the sign up sheets it's never people
who it's never the consumers the
customers who come in and say protect me
from these people who don't know what
they're doing it's always the people who
are already have the licenses or have
some kind of certification or
uh have have jumped over some hurdles
who are trying to turn around and say
nobody else should be able to compete
with me
unless they also jump over this hurdle
so it makes it a kind of fraternity
hazing
um I do have a longer version of my
written testimony which I will provide
and I also have I've written a book
about this very topic which explains why
voluntary licensing is really the way to
go especially New Hampshire I have
copies for anybody who wants one you can
have one for free today
um
so briefly there are five reasons to
support this bill economic political
cultural constitutional and traditional
the economic reason is that apart from
creating a monopolistic price structure
licensing prevents people from offering
specialized and Innovative services and
prevents customers from benefiting from
those services and we're all poorer for
that in terms of money and ideas
there's a political reason as we've
recently seen in the last few years
threatening to pull the licenses of
people
to render them unable to feed and house
themselves to make a living is a primary
tool now that governments use to crush
opposition to official policies whether
misguided or not and even to get people
to stop having certain kinds of of
conversations in California right now if
you disagree with the governor about
covid you can have your license pulled
there's a cultural reason as everybody
knows and I I'm sure all of you know
Pollux politics is Downstream of culture
people get the government that they
understand that they want that they
deserve
and if you live in a place where you
literally have to ask permission to make
a living
that actually undermines culturally the
experience of Freedom that's necessary
to sustain the idea of freedom
politically if you get used to just
thinking of yourself as a resource and
the state can say well you're essential
but you're not
and what you do is important and I'm
going to micromanage your business you
start stop thinking of yourself as a
citizen you start thinking yourself as
something much more like a farm animal
there's a constitutional reason if you
check out article 83 of the State
Constitution it actually identifies the
right of the people and the
responsibility of the state
the right is that the people have an
inherent and essential right to free and
Fair competition in the trades and
industries and the state the
responsibility is the state has a
responsibility to protect them from all
monopolies that would hinder or destroy
that right all monopolies not just
private monopolies but State monopolies
too
and Licensing when you distill it to its
effort its Essence is in fact a
Government monopoly that destroys
competition by saying some people can do
some things and other people can't
it isn't just a bad idea it is
flagrantly unconstitutional
and there's a traditional reasonable
finally so remember many of you probably
remember when you were promised if you
like your health plan you can keep it
that turned out to be a lie but it
encompasses the spirit of this bill if
you like being able to tell your
potential customers that you are
licensed by the state you can still do
it if you need to have a license in
order because you want to do the bulk of
your building through Insurance you can
do it nobody's stopping you right and if
you trust the government
to protect you from slip shot or you
know just uh from bad people slip shot
Shady people you you're free to say I'm
only going to deal with people who have
a government license it doesn't change
anything this takes away nothing from
anybody
but at the same time it actually
Embraces traditionally the Live Free or
Die Spirit of New Hampshire which is the
freedom of each person to decide for
himself how much risk he's willing to
accept and which of the many
non-government mechanisms for
negotiating and mitigating that risk he
prefers to rely on so the beauty of this
bill is it offers certification but
without coercion it offers reassurance
but without repression and it offers
protection without paternalism and I
urge you to in the strongest possible
terms to vote for it
thank you very much if anybody wants a
book we can give them to you okay we'll
definitely make sure to have one for the
file if nothing else all right
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill 507
all right seeing none I will close the
public hearing
and the committee will resume at 1 15.
what you finished right on time anyway
foreign
welcome to Edna I'm opening the public
hearing on House Bill 594.
and is the is there the sponsor or
someone else's
yes
foreign
thank you madam chair and committee
members thank you for giving me the
opportunity to introduce house bill 594.
for the record I am representative Joe
Shapiro from Keen Cheshire 16
representing Keen Ward 2 Alstead Gilson
Harrisville Sullivan starter Roxbury
Marlboro Marlow and Nelson it took me a
long time to get that
um
having served on last year's committee
to study and make recommendations
relative to licensure and Mental Health
Professions I'm here today to introduce
one of the several bills coming out of
that committee's work
HB 594 was written with the
collaboration of oplc
and I'm not really sure if there's
somebody from oplc to testify after me
this spill makes a small but important
change in the statute related to
reciprocity and all the boards operating
under oplc
RSA 310a as we heard in our study
committee portability is often
um a difficult process so when someone
has a license in another state comes to
New Hampshire and applies for an
equivalent license that process has
um long been more onerous and
complicated than many think it should be
so this tries to in a very small way to
address some of the concerns around
portability or some people might refer
to it as reciprocity
the key language to be aware of in this
bill is is on page one line six through
eight
provided the jurisdictions licensing
requirements of substantially similar to
New Hampshire's licensing requirements
as determined by the executive director
in other words assessing the equivalence
of licensing requirements between the
two relevant States a complex and
onerous task for a volunteer board will
now be the responsibility of the
director of oplc
rather than each individual board this
will now be the case with all the boards
under the jurisdiction of oplc
um
because of the study committee that I
was on
um
the intention at first was to remove
obstacles for
the board of mental health the board of
substance use disorder
clinicians and the board of
psychologists
but the bill kind of morphed into
something a little bit different to
address a very small issue but in all of
the boards under oplc
and I'd be very willing to take
questions thank you very much for your
testimony are there questions
I'd like to thank you for it because
some years ago I asked the boards to
rule or at least post where they had
decided that some
States requirements were substantially
similar and I don't believe any board
ever made that determination public
so I appreciate your uh taking it out of
there well I hope that this will address
that and now that the staff of oplc can
do this that they'll not only
do it but do it thoroughly and have it
um
clearly available for the public and
clearly available for people who are
applying
yes exactly that was my and I will say
that my intention when I first proposed
this bill was to have
um
yeah
a substitute
for when Bill when when licenses were
not substantially similar from the other
state if the requirements were less in
the other state than in New Hampshire
that we could substitute a certain
number of years of practice in good
standing from those other states so that
proved too complicated at the last
minute with OLS and all the boards
having different
um
you know different types of licensees
and different requirements but that is
something I hope to bring in the future
thank you very much are there any other
questions representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair
so uh
to the degree you put it in the hands of
the executive director uh you are
subjecting yourself to the possibility
of an executive director who don't like
to do it that way
um so have you given consideration to
that possibility I I see the advantage
obviously but what about the
disadvantages
well I have long been a licensed social
worker in the state of New Hampshire
although I don't practice anymore so
I've I've often dealt with
the board of mental health practice and
I think um
and as you know as you probably hear all
the time people talk about
um Workforce shortage especially in
mental health and one of only one part
of the puzzle is that it's
um
people complain about the licensing
process and I think there are two issues
when it comes for licensing there there
are the laws things like we're trying to
address today but there's also the
actual functioning of the boards and I
think
you know at various times in my career
you could always call the board of
mental health practice and there was
someone who'd been there for a long time
and was incredibly knowledgeable and
give you the answer you needed and then
at other times there were people
changing all the time and there was a
volunteer board and they had a hard time
going in a quorum and they had a hard
time meeting to make decisions on these
things so
I think
of course anything could go wrong but I
think having a paid professional staff
doing this function will give it a
better chance of actually happening on a
across the across the boards
follow-up follow-up okay so the thing is
uh I see the advantages as you do
um but to some degree uh any mental
health is mental health pretty well ever
aware cause planet or Nationwide for
sure uh some some boards would be uh it
would be less I mean the type of
structure that they build uh in the
South versus North is influenced by
climate topography it's culture and so
forth and so on so the architecture
board would would be more
uh chat a hard challenge hard put to
um to discover or to determine
compatibility suitability uh you know
and so forth uh then mental health
practice your field
um so
in putting it in the hands of the
executive director you're taking away
the board's expertise
so how about that aspect
thank you for the question
um the actual wording
is as determined by the executive
director in culture in consultation with
the boards and commissions
so the intention of having them be
involved in the process is certainly
there
right and that is that is the
consultation usually means the the
executive director would not
uh overrule the input from the board
is that your understanding of it because
in in creating a record here that would
be helpful to know
to tell you the truth I haven't really
thought that through but also more
importantly
I don't think what I think about that or
the way I would go about doing it if I
was the executive director and how I
would relate to the boards
I don't think that's necessarily
relevant to the way the people who were
employed now would do it I mean some of
it is you know individual management
style
thank you very much
any other questions representative first
is this going to go to licensing
subcommittee if it needs to go to a
subcommittee that's the one that we'll
go to yes okay thank you um
defend the question is if if we do have
a subcommittee to work on this which I
don't know that we will would you be
available to uh to help us out I will do
my best to do that okay thank you
and not seeing any other questions thank
you for your testimony
um
Sarah Holland
hello again thank you madam chair and
thank you committee members my name is
Sarah Holland I'm a licensed real estate
broker I'm here on behalf of the New
Hampshire Realtors we are opposed to HP
594 as it's currently written we
understand that it may have the intent
behind it to apply to one or some but
not all professions of the oplc and
we'll submit that last year HB 1354 was
passed and went into effect last August
and this bill
allows for a recognition of real estate
licenses in other states provided that
they first pass the New Hampshire
portion of the licensing exam so this
bill HB 594 would kind of upturn that
recognition recognition process and
apply reciprocity and the difference
would be in that testing portion and for
those licensees to prove that they
understand and have a basis in the New
Hampshire law to better protect to
Consumers and from my own personal
experience I am currently licensed in
two states New Hampshire and Vermont and
I could tell you that their laws are
vastly different I was previously
licensed in four and I licensed I was
licensed in Massachusetts through
recognition I took an exam in order to
prove that I understood the
Massachusetts laws and regulations
however from Massachusetts to my
licensure in Connecticut they said oh
we're fine you can just have a license
which was
unnerving to me I did not feel
comfortable practicing in Connecticut
having zero requirement of their laws
and rules and regulations
um so
I can attest that the laws are
incredibly different in each state and
having that basic knowledge that
recognition requires not reciprocity is
simply the lowest bar that we should
have for Consumer Protection
happy to take any questions thank you I
would say that even as someone who knows
almost nothing about real estate I I'm
aware that the
laws in the licenses in Massachusetts or
Vermont or Maine are not substantially
similar to New Hampshire because of our
weird land laws absolutely so I think
that that's a the simplest explanation
is that they're not substantially
similar and they can't be substantially
similar yes so
if that's agreed thank you any other
questions representative schuette
thank you madam chair thank you very
much for taking my question
um having been involved in drafting some
of the rules for oplc myself last term I
was insistent that that phrase in
consultation with the awards commissions
and councils be included on several
instances
have you had the opportunity to make
consultations with the director and have
you encountered difficulties with that
um we are in um conversation with the
director we we have um
brought her to our organization to speak
and be updated and we have we do have
um a good line of communication with her
absolutely
um our concern was that there may be
some confusion in how this bill is
written based on what we previously
passed last year relative to our
specific industry so we just wanted to
clarify and be on record doing so
okay thank you other questions
all right seeing none thank you very
much
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill 594.
I was going to have a questions
ah well then it's a good thing she's
volunteered yes
director oh you have a question
for whom sorry for our uh executive
director Courtney
invite to uh up to speak yes
I didn't think you could Escape did you
good afternoon for the record Lindsey
Courtney executive director office of
professional life insurance
certification and we have to answer your
question representative because
um
thank you so
a number of concerns one is that if
House Bill 409 which you know you're
you're involved in uh an amendment for
that were to be adopted by the
legislature and going along it looks
like this would override it and uh
eliminate the general reciprocity that
was the intent to that so my question is
is that correct and and related
are there any other licenses where there
are some
reciprocity provisions
that might be less restrictive where
passing this would would make it more
restrictive
so I'll answer the second question first
which is I'm not aware of any that are
less restrictive and actually in 332g
I think it's 12
which only applies to our title 30 words
it doesn't apply to our non-title 30
boards I believe they use the term
substantial substantially equivalent
we chose to use substantially similar
um maybe there's not too much of a
distinction but the the intent was to be
a little bit less restrictive because
what we've observed is that equivalency
language is often utilized even if you
meet 95 of the requirements like what is
substantially equivalent substantially
similar would give us a little bit more
flexibility in assessing those uh
requirements in terms of the other
question as to how many other
reciprocity type statutes exist most
boards have some language in their
individual practice acts that allow them
to promulgate rules and licensure
requirements for individuals who are
licensed in other jurisdictions I would
say though that the boards have not
consistently exercised that Authority
and also the requirements very
substantially
when I think of reciprocity or
portability I think of essentially if
you have another jurisdiction with very
similar requirements
um not requiring that person to jump
through extra Hoops to get a license
um
some boards have license types that are
based on endorsement but actually
require them to do more than a licensed
person
who takes an examination
the board of psychology for example if
you they have a licensure by endorsement
or a reciprocity they still have to go
and get their supervisors to sign off
even if they've been licensed for 30
years in addition to getting
verifications of licensure
so globally what this is intended to do
is create one process for the office to
manage and Implement as it relates to
portability the idea was to take it out
of 332g because that doesn't apply to
all of our boards put it in our statute
because it applies to all of our boards
and because we've observed that null
actually I don't think any board has
made an official determination under
332g as to what other states are
substantially equivalent we thought by
giving it to the oplc in consultation
with the boards that would kind of force
the issue a little bit we would have a
little bit more control over making that
happen implementing it
um so I hope that answers your question
follow up yeah uh it it largely does I
still have a specific question about HP
409 where we're looking at assuming that
we're going to law do something was
actually a little less restrictive than
this so
um would it require some amendment to
this to to let 409 work if it were and
then if the answer is yes if you could
work with us on some language
I actually think it would obviate the
need for HP 409 because this would
create a structure
um where essentially Most states are for
cosmetology anyways are substantial if
not all states are substantially similar
to our requirements I think we heard
that testimony with respect to HP 409
you know there are some hours
differences but um when we talk about
similarities
um I would not Envision a scenario where
jurisdictions would be eliminated and
the other thing that I would offer with
respect to the experience issue that was
discussed by representative Shapiro we
have a similar language in the massage
statute which is an Advisory Board and
we just promulgated some rules using
this language that allows us to take
into consideration experience if the
hours requirements of another
jurisdiction does not is not the same as
our hours requirement so I do think
under under rules that could be
certainly something that we consider as
well because if you've participated in a
cosmetology program that's you know a
thousand hours ours is 1500 but you've
practiced for 30 years you know is that
not a substantially similar requirement
I think
one could make that argument pursuant to
rules
okay thank you I was not reading
substantially similar as broadly as you
apparently were and it's actually true
that with this language
you can put in place rules that would
help you define what we get approval for
defining what you you know how broad
that range is I guess the question
yeah I think we would rely on our
existing rulemaking authority to
implement that
um again that is a question right what
is substantially similar and we've had a
couple of boards undergo basically a
policy audit through a contract that we
had a couple years back one of them was
the board of Licensing for alcohol and
drug use counselors and they did a whole
analysis a nationwide as to what every
State's requirements were
and we're able to present to us if you
determine that substantially similar is
70 of the requirements you're you know
you're going to get 30 States for
example
um if it's 80 you're only going to get
eight you know so what is the percentage
in terms of the requirements as to what
is substantially equivalent the board
hasn't made that determination yet so we
would like to work with them to make
that determination and I I think it's
fairly broad as to what's substantially
similar okay thank you
any other questions
Schmidt
thank you madam chair
uh so the thing is with your legal
background you're probably unusually
qualified to get into that but the thing
is this is going to require much more
engagement from you on these types of
issues obviously to the degree you can
depend on boards to provide you with
good information it's not going to be
you like Atlas lifting the world uh but
um
it is going to be more work is is that
an aspect that uh who have reservations
about this bill
no I actually think it'll be helpful to
the office because right now we are
managing and trying to
um
basically harmonize
statutes with the same intent but with
different language you know you've got
the reciprocity language in 332g you've
got an each practice act you've got some
temporary licensure it would be nice to
have one
um that we could look to and work with
the boards to implement
under oplc statute that would certainly
be a statutory directive to us to make
sure that we have
um we're meeting the requirements of
this proposed statute so you know
essentially we would move forward with
working with the boards and my
expectation is that they would work with
us and provide us with their feedback
but if they didn't the end result would
be we would do it without them which is
why I think they would probably
participate and we would actually get a
solution
that I mean the fact that this this bill
becoming the statute gives you a pretty
big hammer uh and so uh as long as
you're comfortable with the idea of
proceeding you're going to be the
executive director for another 15 20
years right
um so the bottom line is as I say with
your legal background you're you're
going to be have a different capacity
than somebody who doesn't have that but
if as long as you're comfortable with it
that's important thank you and just for
your awareness we're we're lining things
up and establishing internal control so
that the the management of the office is
not reliant on one person so I I feel
really confident with their ability to
execute that and the only other thing
representative if I may or Madam chair
um with respect to
um Miss Holland's testimony which I I
very much appreciate I think the way I
would interpret
um the phrase substantially similar as I
would actually exclude the New Hampshire
real estate licensing requirements out
of it so I I don't think that that the
requirements in Massachusetts would be
deemed substantially similar because
there is a jurisprudence examination
component that is based on different
laws
um and so I don't believe that we would
issue those types of licenses under this
statute yes thank you I believe the the
board of uh surveyors has the same
situation yes certainly
okay representative and thank you thank
you um so since we never know what's
going to happen to a bill
um we don't know what will happen with
this one if we were to move forward with
409 and it were to pass and then this
one were as well
my reading is that it wouldn't be a
problem uh this might override that one
but do substantially the same thing so
is that uh reasonable
yes that would be my interpretation it
wouldn't be modifying the same statute
so we would just look to both and
um harmonize the consistency to be the
broadest
um to apply the broadest interpretation
thank you
no I had had my hand raised but uh the
director anticipated my question on the
Realty board and answered that so I'm
all set great okay excellent anyone else
have a question
thank you very much
all right that's uh
does anyone else wish to testify on
House Bill 594
seeing anybody will close the hearing
and um
so the question you a subcommittee was
raised if you reached a decision on that
or I I don't believe it needs to go to
subcommittee we think we can discuss it
in the executive session I I agree with
that but I just wanted to have your
deterior yeah I agree because uh it it
doesn't sound like there's a need for an
amendment which is what I was concerned
about which is good
in fact since we have 20 minutes do you
want
you want to exact this
I'm fine I mean it's time to me
Jackie Jackie
yeah yeah
I I think we understand it and it
doesn't seem to need an amendment so
it's up to you
okay
yeah
okay in that case we'll we'll go into
executive session on House Bill 594
reports
does someone have a motion
if nobody else wants to I'll make a
motion about to pass second
okay representative second of our
representative Schmidt
excellent
do you wish to speak to your motion uh
briefly yeah I mean it's uh
we've we've
allowing if someone's license somewhere
else and it's at least reasonably uh
similar requirements I don't see any
reason why they should not be able to
get a license in practice in New
Hampshire
representative do you wish to say
something oh I think we
this is a solid enough procedure to go
forward with
okay thank you anyone else wish to
comment question represent goalie thank
you madam chair and I will just state
that I was happy to hear the director's
response to uh the concerns the board of
realtors had and I think that is taken
care of so I'm all set with voting in
support of this
yes okay thank you anyone else
all right seeing none the motion is
ought to pass by representative Senator
blackis and the clerk can call the rule
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey
yes representative Santo nastasso
yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative Weber yes
representative Gerhard yes clerk votes
yes representative groda
yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie
yes representative shewitt yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
and the chair yes
and we have a vote of 18 yay zero name
excellent the emotion passes 18-0 is
there any objection to consent
all right seeing none will put that on
consent
a little quickly it's probably getting
late
so
where they're they're busy dealing with
the reports that have been returned in
this last night this morning
unless you have one ready
Representatives uh milacas
all right okay
okay this is uh that's the end of the
executive session and we will
we have 15 minutes until our next
hearing that one
it's been loud enough thank you
thank you very much for the record my
name is representative Rosemary rung and
I represent Hillsboro District 12 which
is the town of Merrimack
um the prime sponsor of this bill
representative Diane power is unable to
be here she's in executive session with
her committee but as a co-sponsor and a
supporter of this I'm very happy to
introduce the bill to you
um hb's excuse me representative Brian
somebody's phone is going berserk
thank you
ah thank you we shut it off okay please
please resume okay thank you no no
worries so HP 644 is a bill to
streamline and simplify the requirements
for beauty shop licenses and to exempt
three services from occupational and
Shop licenses I'd like to First address
um the simplifying the requirements of
beauty shops to the first point
regarding beauty shop licenses the bill
this bill repeals the license
requirement for individuals who
independently operate booths attach to
or within an already licensed Salon or
barber shop
please please excuse us that's okay
technological failure
okay sorry would you like me to continue
please Madam chair okay as you may be
aware it's not uncommon for a
hairdresser to rent a stall at a beauty
shop owned and operated by another
hairdresser often this occurs when the
owner has extra chairs or sinks dryers
or chairs
other setups that the number of stylists
she or he employees and wants to use and
has extra to use to rent to defray the
costs so it's usually a salon maybe
there's six setups but she only has
she's only employing maybe three
stylists she may rent those other setups
in my experience and I have frequented
hair salons often over my years a
customer cannot distinguish between the
rented stalls and those which are owned
and operated by the stud the the the
owner of The Stylist at work it doesn't
make much sense to require the rented
stalls to have a separate shop license
from the shop license already required
of the owner of that shop
and that that requirement is in RSA
313-a colon a19 a colon 19.
this bill also exempts three Niche
Beauty services from occupational and
Shop license requirements these services
are shampooing and blow dry styling
threading and makeup applications under
current statute individuals who do
desire to provide these limited Beauty
services to clients must have a
cosmetology barbering and Aesthetics
license issued by the state
currently in order to become a licensed
Beauty provider in New Hampshire a
person must invest substantial time and
money oftentimes incurring significant
financial debt
in New Hampshire the average cosmetology
program costs over nineteen thousand
dollars
it costs two hundred dollars for the
exam and a person must must have 1500
hours of Education time
in comparison only 150 education hours
are required for an EMT to become
licensed
so really does shampooing blow drying
running a thread over someone's eyebrows
or applying makeup pose such a public
health risk to mandate this extensive
cost and regulation
moreover these occupational licensing
requirements disproportionately affect
economically disadvantaged individuals
the majority of whom are women
we need to focus on making it easier for
them to launch into a profession by
removing unnecessary and expensive
obstacles
as far as the salons dedicated only to
shampooing blow drying threading and
makeup application these are very
different from traditional First full
service salons first they offer only
three these basic Niche Services which
are inherently safe
they do not use or store chemicals that
permanently alter the shape or color of
hair or skin
Threading salons use cotton thread and
is the most ancient the safest and
natural forms of hair removal it does
not involve the use of debilitatory
chemicals hot waxes or Sharp Tools
and unlike traditional for full-service
salons blow dry bars offer safe limited
services including shampooing
conditioning blow drying and styling of
hair
these specialty salons do not cut hair
nor do they use chemicals or dyes blow
dry bars not to be confused with other
common bars we may know of are no
different than Hair Braiding salons
which were Exempted in 2017 by the New
Hampshire General Court from State
Licensing by the Board of barbering
cosmetology and Aesthetics
shampooing blow drying using cotton
thread and applying makeup are
activities that thousands of granite
Staters do every day themselves even
children do them without the requirement
to go to school to learn them we should
not require time intensive and expensive
requirements for someone who simply
wants to do it for income so I recommend
House Bill 644 ought to pass and I hope
you join me thank you and I'm happy to
entertain any questions thank you
representative are there any questions
representative Lucas
thank you my only question is if you
have that testimonial written form and
you haven't emailed it would you please
do so yeah I'll actually hand it out if
you could email I'll email it to correct
thank you
representative
hi thank you
I believe we heard this bill last year
does it say something about eyelash
extensions
thank you for the question
representative that was removed from
this bill
okay thank you yep so this bill says
nothing whatsoever about eyelashes no um
eyelash extensions do require an
adhesive that's applied near the eye
it's on the eyelash so there was concern
last year that that was part of the bill
so
um representative power and and I had
discussions with her about it last year
removed it from this version
it's representative Gould
if um if someone else is going to
testify who could answer this better
thank you madam chair
um my question is in order to understand
fully if you could explain the cotton
threading of the eyebrow
somebody could probably answer that I
haven't I I use the dangerous tweezers
so I don't really know about the cotton
threading but I have heard it's very
safe it's and it's an extremely old
ancient form of removing here
representative true
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question and you'll see that I
don't get out much
um but uh
so uh a person would go to a salon and
say I'm just here for a shampoo and blow
dry my hair
yes
but follow up
and and
this would not be at a hair salon where
somebody's renting
a booth and all they're doing at that
Booth is shampooing and blow drying your
hair
with this bill that is correct there
could be someone someone let's say for
yourself for example could go into a
full-service Salon which is licensed and
there may be a stylist there who's only
job they're allowed to do without the
license is I mean if this bill to Pat
were to pass could all she could only or
he could only shampoo and blow dry your
hair
thank you but presently that's not true
someone that's only limited to those
tasks could still be
um does the state currently requires a
license to do that
but this would not prohibit a licensed
cosmetologist from doing this should
they choose correct and and thank you
for that comment also it additionally if
you look at it from a business
perspective
um someone who's gone through that
extensive training and to become a
licensed cosmetologist
um they have dispense part of their day
shampooing and blow drying and if they
were relieved of those very basic tasks
they could get more value added
opportunities value-added task to their
day so it actually improves the value of
the revenue that that Salon could do
because they wouldn't have to have these
trained licensed cosmetologists to do
basic tasks they'd be freed up to do
more complicated work
okay representative a bear
am I allowed to clarify that question
for my colleague
you want to make a statement
um not normally no no okay thank you
all right
we'll take it offline representative
Broda
so by removing I guess it's a question
for anybody who can answer it by
removing arranging dressing curling
waving cleansing
from the definition of Cosmetology
cutting bleaching coving killing
chemically altering
between the hair does that mean that
cosmetologists can no longer arrange
dress curl wave and cleanse hair
no
to why we take it if it is if it is not
you don't need a license for it then the
cosmetologist can do it
well I mean that's I think we're getting
into uh I'm just clarifying we're not
getting into anything I'm just clever I
have no I I just want to understand this
because this is something that we have
had before us and I just want to make
sure foreign
yes representative Schmidt so is this
going to a subcommittee it sounds like
it needs to right okay because I don't
think we should get into all this stuff
but I I was also going to ask whether
representative a bear could uh phrase a
question that would bring out the kind
of thing that you want to
make a statement about maybe you could
ask a question because this is an area
as you can see that I'm not too very
qualified in uh nor do I want to be for
that matter but but I I do think that
this is important because we're talking
about businesses that are you know
flourishing or uh or you know maybe not
but they would like to so let's get it
right
all right thank you representative
I have a question
so
a little Act of listening what you're
saying is that someone who might be
answering the phone only
during a busy Salon time on a Saturday
could prep somebody's hair by washing it
and preparing it for the licensed
um
cosmetologist exactly so it allows the
licensed cosmetology to work on tasks
that require more training or that are
handling chemicals that may need extra
safety precautions that they've been
trained to handle so somebody that's in
the salon or student perhaps that isn't
licensed yet would be able to shampoo
and blow dry do those basic tasks to
free up the time of the licensed
cosmetologist
okay
all right representative Schmidt uh it
seems to me that we've had situations in
the past where we've been told that uh
that some salons are offering free
services and so forth uh and they're
having them done by people who are not
trained uh and uh is there not a danger
that we will see abuse of this bill
possibly by situations where some salons
will advertise free services but they
won't be performed by cosmetologists and
other licensed Personnel they will be
performed by people who've been hired to
be
receptionists or schedulers or whatever
where they don't they don't have any
training at all well thank you
representative for that question I would
imagine that if a business is offering
free services performed by someone who's
unlicensed for that task would be in
violation of New Hampshire law
um so they wouldn't be but if they're
offering free services that are
performed by somebody who doesn't
require a license
um I don't really see a problem with
that I I also kind of correlate this if
we look at the field of an electrician a
master electrician can do anything
that's needed to do for a wiring project
whether it's industrial commercial or
residential but there are certain tasks
that involve wiring that can be done by
someone who's not licensed it could be
lining up the tools or purchasing the
supplies removing
um uh electrical plates you know if if
we require a light a master election
electrician to do all those tasks that's
less time that they can devote to
those tasks which actually require a
higher level of training with this bill
the the premise is that you don't
require extensive training you're not
posing a public health risk by having
someone shampoo blow dry your hair or
apply your makeup
for representative shouldn't we realize
you're not a consumer representative
Gerhard thank you madam chair just
curiosity's sake has there ever been any
instances of Barbers gone wrong and I
mean just with shampooers is there any
instance of people actually suffering
from
unlicensed shampooers I'm just curious
like is there
um uh thank you for the question I'm not
aware of any but as a customer of these
Services even if I go into a shop where
there is a licensed cosmetologist there
may be some factors of that that I said
yeah I don't really want to be there
maybe just the style or maybe the
product they're using is it something
that I like so the customer still has a
decision making it customers still can
assess whether the shop they're going to
the the cosmetologist maybe isn't
practicing hygiene the way they should
under a license but I think we have to
give credit to the customer to assess a
situation where they may be at risk
thank you any other questions thank you
very much all right thank you very much
and I will um distribute my written
testimonial email it to the committee as
well thank you uh Ross Connolly
thank you madam chair members of the
committee always great to be back in
ocdna uh for the record my name is Ross
Connolly I'm the deputy state director
for Americans for Prosperity here to
voice our support for HB 644
um as was mentioned this is a bill that
uh should be familiar to the veterans of
this committee it came up last year uh
and passed overwhelmingly in the house
and and uh a lot of the criticism of the
bill in the Senate was around the uh the
eyelash extensions so the compromise
that that we came up in response uh to
that was to remove that section uh since
there there could be a a concern of of
adhesives
um being used in that process but this
bill
um simply uh removes the license
licensure requirement for styling hair
and makeup application as well as those
uh those separate booths within salons
that was mentioned by the previous
speaker
um all of these these uh services are
very low risk to the consumer it's just
styling hair getting ready for a prom
getting ready for a wedding getting your
your hair styled obviously if you look
at me I don't have much experience in
this area but um it is a a very popular
uh very popular service that's that's
growing especially in States outside of
New Hampshire as far as I know we do
have two blow dry bars in in New
Hampshire one in Bedford I believe the
others in Salem
um but uh Hudson as representative
lekkas points out
um I I
you know we if we want to see this
industry grow uh it's really onerous to
require these very Niche services to go
through the thousands of hours it takes
to get a cosmetology license the uh
enormous expense of of getting uh of
going to the school and and the expense
of the license so uh we look at this
very similar to when we supported the
the bill that removed the requirement
for hair braiders uh back in 2017 uh
it's very similar very low risk to
Consumers and uh and and could be a big
economic boom for these these folks that
maybe they want to uh get the full
cosmetology license later on and and
grow into the industry that this gives
them a foothold to start earning money
uh in this area and they can eventually
afford the school if they want to
provide the full Suite of services
um so with that uh we think that this is
a great legislation and and encourage
the the committee to to move this bill
out to pass and I'd be happy to take any
questions if there are any
thank you for
sure thank you madam chair so
one of the things that has not really
been discussed in our hearing thus far
is a question of hygiene uh we've been
talking about procedures
but hygiene is a big deal uh whenever
you're dealing with people handling
other people's hair nails or whatever
and and so what
uh Provisions you see uh being
influenced by this bill involving
hygiene uh thank you for the question
representative as uh representative
wrong mentioned
um this is a service most of these
services are very obvious if there is a
mistake uh the to the consumer the nails
aren't painted right the the hair isn't
styled right uh the greatest check on
that is is the consumer not returning to
that uh establishment so uh we believe
that the market forces really protect
the consumer the most in this area
because there is not a an enormous risk
of of bodily harm the biggest risk is is
uh you know your your service not
meeting the standards that that you want
to be met so uh the consumer really has
a lot of choice in this area follow-up
well not coming back certainly is uh the
the not the ultimate a slap in the face
to the establishment of the the biggest
slap in the face would be a lawsuit
because they somebody did something
wrong so the
establishment suffers by the customer
not coming back or something was done
wrong but the customer is harmed
potentially by that and so that's a
concern I have with regard to whether
you think you this is an area you have
testified before so on a number of
occasions previously so I are you
satisfied that that this aspect of
somebody who has potentially no training
could be doing this kind of thing and in
terms of hygiene which can you know
conveys disease potentially uh thank you
for the question representative I I we
certainly believe so uh that the the
risk is very low and for those those
larger risks whether it's fraud or
damages actual they find a way to to
make bodily harm that those things are
still able to to go through a a civil
suit process there would be a an ability
to to get restitution and very extreme
circumstances
um you know the license requirement is
really a threat that will take away the
license uh so those those other avenues
still exist it's just the the
requirement for the licensure is is
removed thank you representative O'Brien
earlier today uh thank you for taking my
question thank you madam chair
um use electricians as the example I
could go to work for an electrician as a
journeyman or Apprentice yet I am
working underneath that patrician's
license
if my
um
performance was substandard okay it
caused a particular issue that comes to
the responsibility of the master
licensed technician
you're talking about computer uh
consumer protection I just don't show up
you get a bad haircut don't show up but
what happens if something more serious
uh why not having uh is there any
guaranteed a shop owner or anybody there
are you working why wouldn't you have it
that they're working under that person's
particular ticket
thank you for the question
representative if I'm right or is this
in reference to the the salon a booth uh
so that that's obviously
um you're working in a licensed Salon in
that instance uh and you have that
oversight uh we think that's very
appropriate that person can again grow
into the industry learn uh real skills
in in real time uh so that we think
that's a very appropriate check on on
that similar to to electricians when it
comes to the niche Beauty Services
um you know if if someone messes up your
your electrical work there could be
serious consequences
um I I am not an expert in in doing
electrical work I usually have my
brother or somebody do that but um I the
I do style hair I do it every morning I
comb it not very well but I think most
most people are proficient in that area
and and that's the area where we think
that the market forces
um are are a good solution to to uh you
know bad performance
follow up
um I'm not very comfortable with having
the market determine it as compared to
having some form of Regulation and
there's nothing I see in there like you
make the suggestion that it could happen
but there's nothing in the law that says
that you must be under the supervision
of a licensed cosmetologist am I correct
in order to style hair correct right and
I also do a good job on my own with my
hair thank you
thank you representative O'Brien Brook
Senator Fitzpatrick
like my colleague to the left I have
very limited experience in any of this
but
I would like
I'm sympathetic to your argument but
could you give me some ease of of that
by describing to me what tools do the
people use when they're performing these
services
I I'm thank you for the question
representative I might not be the best
person to answer this question I I'd
probably defer to those those behind me
uh who have more expertise in in this
this actual field
um you know again we look at it as there
there are alternatives to licensure that
still exist whether that's through
Insurance whether that's through uh
inspections or or uh Market forces and
and for a very very low risk industry
we're talking about styling hair things
that in Massachusetts you know
surrounding states have lower
requirements for and there are growing
number of states that require no
licensure for for these particular
services so
um those are sort of our take on just as
a fault but we're not talking about
scissors are we no
something totally different it's combing
styling gelling uh and cleaning here
okay thank you thank you thank you any
other questions
yes representative
so let's say you go to The Styling bar
and you get your hair done and the
customer says William
do you think you can make my hair a
little shorter
what's gonna happen
thank you for the question
representative if if they actually
perform the cutting of the hair at a
Blow Dry Bar
that would be a violation of of New
Hampshire law
follow up
they're going to be verified
thank you for for the question again I I
think
there is still oversight in this and
since these services do still fall under
the cosmetology board
um you do not need to be licensed for it
but there there would be my
understanding there would still be
oversight and again uh there there's
very little check currently on you know
whether a manicurist is doing things
that they're they're they're not
supposed to the you know people violate
the law uh that but what we're trying to
do is just legalize uh these Services uh
without a license and and it's it should
is very low risk
follow up
so if one of these if an individual will
wanted to open a space up and do this
themselves
outside of Epsilon could they do that
if they wanted to open up a blow dry bar
yes that's the the real purpose of of
much of the legislation
because current currently you need to
get a 1500 plus hours of training uh you
have to spend between eight to forty
thousand dollars on school
um just to if if you wanted to only
provide the service of of cut of styling
and cleaning hair
which in our mind is is quite onerous
yes representative
I I think that the um blow dry bars that
you're you're seeing pop up and I have
seen the one in Hudson I have not seen
the other one
um it is the same terminology as an updo
it's no different than an updo there's
no cutting there's no dying there's no
coloring there's no shaving there's
there it's literally wet your hair
shampoo your hair put some product in
and blow dry it the same you would do it
home other than like there's no epoxies
there's it's just an it's just an updo
I'm on my way out for the night and
that's it is that correct correct it's
it's uh something most of us do maybe
representative Schmidt um aside uh you
know what most of us do every single
morning
I think you look great representative
representative Gould
it's my understanding that uh
common and cosmetology population that
would use this service or not maybe not
predominantly anymore but anyway elderly
people who have trouble raising their
arms what have you so an alternative to
going to a bar would be what maybe
a home health care Aid coming into the
home to shampoo
elderly people's hair
um thank you for the question yeah
current currently I I had a grandparent
in a nursing home for many years that I
looked after and and they would have a a
barber or cosmetologist come to the the
facility but certainly this would help
in providing more options for those
folks that might be disabled and can't
do that do it themselves follow-up and
do you know what kind of cosmetology
training a home health aide has to wash
elderly people's hair I I do not
none none most likely
anyone else
yes representative Gerhart thank you
madam chair
do you
from if you would agree with this or not
I'm not sure but in a situation like
this would you see a voluntary
Association or trade Association forming
just to certify the members of if it was
absent if there was no licensure like
for instance in my experience when I was
younger working in New York City doing
Bridge painting I was like one of the
inspectors as a kid at 18 insane but all
you have to do is decide for protective
Coatings had a certification process do
a test and you're done there's no State
Licensing and you're you know that
that's a serious project there's a lot
of risk involved so do you think that
that the industry itself would form that
in order to protect its reputation or
how do you see that playing out uh thank
you for the question representative uh I
I do not know if there is an industry
you know group that does Private
certifications optional certifications
uh maybe one of the the speakers behind
me does uh but you know voluntary
certification license and and licensure
is something that uh is is a solution in
many different Industries series I know
scuba divers do not have a license it's
a private certification so that's
usually especially for for some of the
other industries that may pose a little
more risk than just styling hair or
painting nails
um that that is is a a good safety check
um you know I I don't know if it'd be
exactly necessary for for this and I'm
I'm unfortunately not able to fully
answer your question whether that exists
or not
yes represent
um Mr Connolly I'd like to mention that
nails are not mentioned because dealing
with nail polish involves a significant
number of nasty chemicals
and Sharp Tools
so that's not included
so anyone other questions all right
thank you thank you very much Sophia
greenmill
I probably mangled your name but
I
foreign
my name is Sophia green Miller Miller oh
yeah pardon me
and you're here to testify yes
I'm a little bit nervous
um so
um I am the owner of um Touch by Sophie
um hair braiding salon in Maine
and um
I've been doing pretty well I opened
during the pandemics and um
it has been good
no yes can you speak into the microphone
like this because we can't hear you okay
and we want to hear what you have to say
okay I am
I'll answer all right thank you that's a
very generous offer are there any
questions representative
can you tell us a little bit about your
business tell us what you do at your
business okay
okay um braiding extensions
on um locks
and
okay thank you thank you very much
yeah
okay
I representative Fitzpatrick has a
question well I'll I'll go to my
original question can you give give this
uh body a
example of the tools that you use
um
clips
also use scissors for the
[Music]
I do shampoo shampoo wash and stuff like
that
that's it thank you blow dry I use a
blow dryer also okay palms and brushes
perhaps
um yes and Combs and brushes yeah sorry
thank you madam chair thank you all
right representative Gerhard and the
neighbor thank you madam chair where do
you stand in decision on this bill do
you support it do you oppose it yes I do
you support it oh yes why do you support
it
um because it has done you know a lot
you know from for me
um
I'm gonna get emotional
um I was born in Jamaica
um
I didn't finish
um Middle School
um
no nobody believed
um but you know believed in me so they
gave up
they gave up on me they said I wasn't
gonna Mount her to be anything good
I'm gonna be a cough
um
so that's when I started
um practicing and doing
um here and
at first I started um Braiding on you
know grass
um you know weeds outside
um
I I wanted to go to school but I I
couldn't afford to so um I started doing
um domestic works like going around and
wash you know people clothes from XYZ
then
um I started to take care of kids where
I live on the premises and um take care
of kids
um do housework and stuff like that
and at one point
um I'd saved up enough money
um
to start school
but then it didn't
the workout I had was to to stop
um from school and just continue working
because I have I had two daughters and
at the time
it wasn't
I couldn't
so
um I just keep practicing practicing
then I started to love doing makeup to
and so at that time I couldn't afford
um the powder that you use on your face
so I would use the chance of baby powder
to make my face cool and then I'll use
either
um the charcoal the black charcoals with
a matchy stick are the black shoes
polish to draw eyebrows
so I
think so um
it's it's my passion and it's not about
money it's it's way deep it's way deeper
and I've have
helped a lot of people
doing here and you know just simply
applying makeup for them most some
people that come to me um you know
they're depressed like me I have Peter's
the depression and
it it helps me just doing my hair you
know doing my face it helps and it helps
a lot of people have traveled do makeup
for
um for wedding and I don't charge here
in New Hampshire in Maine you know
people come out at the shop they just
they come from here and they'll ask me
to teach them how to you know to do
their eyebrows you know what brand
powder what brand
um Foundation Etc
um you know to buy and stuff like that
so
you know it's it's a passion
and
I'm grateful that I'm I'm thankful that
I'm able
to be doing this
thank you thank you for other other
questions
no thank you very much for your
testimony and I hope you'll be able to
add these services to your uh list of of
us Provisions thank you very much
everyone
Connor Norris
Joe McGuire and all distinguished
members of the House Executive
Department's administrative committee
thank you for allowing me to testify on
the regulation of beauty services and
Professionals in the state of New
Hampshire for the record my name is
Connor Norris I'm the assistant director
of the knee center for the study of
Occupational regulation at West Virginia
University
the main takeaways of my comments are
the following
verses that licensing is not always the
appropriate form of Professional
Regulation
second is that Licensing in New
Hampshire reduces economic mobility and
helps contribute to income inequality
and finally more than 20 states have
removed licensing requirements for one
of the niche Beauty professions that's
proposed in this bill
so occupational licensing is one of the
most common forms of Professional
Regulation but it's also one of the most
stringent
so these laws prevent New Hampshire
residents from working in a profession
until they meet certain entry
requirements which include education
training and passing exams
licensing is designed to protect
consumers from harm from low-skilled
professionals and I agree with with
everyone here that this is an important
goal
however licensing is not the only form
of Regulation that we could turn to to
protect consumers
so Langston can be costly and we have to
weigh both the costs and the benefits of
Licensing the Licensing Laws create
barriers to entry and make it more
difficult to enter a profession economic
research estimates that licensing
reduces the number of professionals by
up to 27 in a licensed field
there's many professions that do not
require traditional four-year college
degree that do require a professional
license
these professions offer a meaningful
Avenue for employment for non-college
graduates that is if they can afford to
meet the licensing requirements
unfortunately because of the time and
money it takes for training and
education many are unable to enter these
professions
oh research Bears this out um in a study
published a few years ago
research um yes they found that
Licensing Laws in New Hampshire
increased income inequality by six
percent and decreased economic Mobility
by three percent so they made it that
much harder to you know achieve the
American dream
Niche Beauty Services which include
shampooing hair styling makeup
application eyebrow threading these
types of services provide a good example
of this problem
so economists consistently find evidence
that Licensing Laws act as a barrier to
entry into the beauty professions
while licensing may be worthwhile to
protect consumers from the potential
harms from things like the chemicals
used by Barbers and cosmetologists Niche
Beauty Services don't pose these same
risks to Consumers
so requiring cosmetology licensing for
hair styling or shampooing or an
esthetician license for things like
makeup application and eyebrow threading
imposes all the costs of Licensing that
upfront investment in these Education
meeting those education requirements and
gives consumers none or very few of the
benefits additionally these education
programs cover far more information that
is necessary to perform these tasks
allowing each Beauty services to be
performed without a license would make
New Hampshire one of the leaders in New
England and in the broader Northeast
region but you wouldn't be going out on
a limb according to this super Justice
eight other states have removed
licensing requirements to provide at
least one Niche Beauty service in the
past few years
currently 21 states exempt eyebrow
threaders from the esthetician license
in 14 States makeup artists are exempt
from licensing and 18 states explicitly
exempt shampooers and hair stylists from
the cosmetology license
since removing the licensing requirement
for these Niche Beauty professions
States haven't experienced a surge in
consumer injuries so far we see no
evidence of lower quality services being
provided or consumer harms resulting
from the licensure and we also don't see
consumer advocacy groups calling for
re-licensure
additionally no states have decided to
re-licens the practice since removing
licensing
so although Licensing Laws are designed
to protect consumers from harm they're
not always the appropriate form of
regulations to achieve those goals for
Niche Beauty Services consumers face
little risk of injury or harm however
both consumers and the aspiring Beauty
professionals still face the full cost
of licensure so New Hampshire has the
opportunity to grow and join a growing
number of states to remove unnecessary
licensing requirements for these safe
Niche Beauty professions
I'd like to thank you for your time and
I'm happy to answer any questions you
have
thank you are there any questions
representative Schmidt
thank you ma'am sure you mentioned
eyebrow threading I thought that was not
involved here
eyelashes are not involved here
and he used the term eyebrow threading
that is specifically allowed yes okay
and what is eyebrow threaded
that
is that
the proximity to the eyes is troubling I
can help yes representative can answer
your question
please
[Music]
well I've never had it done nor have I
ever done it but you use Twisted threads
and you pull them
through your eyebrows and instead of
plucking your eyebrow with a tweezer it
takes the
um
I bet you never knew
all the things that we worry about
when it comes to eyebrows but anyway
that's what it is it doesn't use any
sharp input it's just a thread a twisted
thread that's used and it's pulled and
it pulls the aisle the um extra whatever
whatever you want to pull out of your
eyebrow
but you have magnificent eyebrows and I
would say that you shouldn't touch them
foreign
I just get out the Hedge cutter and cut
them every every couple of weeks so I
can see the rest of the world
an advanced Beauty technique even though
it's not dangerous
thanks thank you are there other
questions
all right seeing them thank you very
much
Jennifer poitrus
he's obviously reading from a prepared
statement if you have you given that us
to your remarks
that would be appreciated thank you
good afternoon chairman McGuire and
members of the executive departments and
administration committee
thank you for the opportunity to testify
in support of House Bill 644 which would
create more jobs and opportunities for
aspiring Beauty entrepreneurs my name is
Jessica Patois and I am legislative
council with the institute for justice
The Institute for justice is a national
nonprofit organization that advocates
for civil liberties including economic
Liberty for nearly 30 years we have
helped reform beauty industry laws in
over 24 States through litigation and
legislative efforts
New Hampshire's Beauty Industries ripe
with opportunity but current Licensing
Laws shut people out of jobs
New Hampshire requires Beauty service
professionals to have one of the big
three licenses which includes the
cosmetology or barber license and an
esthetician's license or a manicurist
license
grouping all Beauty Services into one of
these three overbought licenses does not
work for an industry that is based on
creativity and evolving techniques our
data licensing requirements also Force
Beauty professionals into time-consuming
and costly traditional cosmetology
programs even when those programs do not
teach the services that aspiring
professionals would like to offer
traditional cosmetology Licensing Laws
prevent Niche Beauty service
professionals from entering into the
industry
as you've heard today the niche Beauty
service profession professions that are
covered in 644 include blow dry styling
makeup application and threading and I'm
happy to provide a more detailed
explanation of what all three of those
services are
during The Question portion of this
hearing these services are different
than the big three licenses because they
do not use dangerous tools chemicals or
dyes they are limited in scope of
practice and Niche Beauty professionals
train outside of traditional cosmetology
programs so instead of cosmetologists
who go to school to learn how to do all
of the beauty Services these individuals
do not learn their skills in those
programs they actually learn them
outside of those programs
typically through private certifications
or apprenticeship models things things
of that nature
even if they do even if cosmetology
schools do teach these programs like
some teach basic makeup Artistry that's
exactly what it is they teach it at a
very rudimentary level these
professionals gain their skills and they
improve on their skills
um by either undergoing private
certification or apprenticeship or
working under
um uh you know like a beauty master or
something like that
the average student in New Hampshire
takes out seventy three hundred dollars
worth of federal student loans to
complete their first program and most
students do not graduate on time in 2016
through 2017 only about 19 of
Cosmetology students graduated on time
in New Hampshire
their peers were forced to incur even
more debt to finish this training
the result being that many Niche Beauty
professionals work in underground
economies where they face exploitation
or they continue to incur insurmountable
debt to complete that training
without giving them any additional
benefit nor providing consumers with any
additional benefit
House Bill 644 is a solution for
aspiring Beauty professionals based off
of proven methods of Reform that have
created jobs and opportunities in other
states
I encourage this committee to support
this bill for three reasons first as I
mentioned before Niche Beauty services
are safe blow dry styling makeup
application and threading pose virtually
no risk to Consumers I work on this
piece or on this type of legislation
across the country and I have not yet
seen an enforcement about one of these
Beauty service providers harming someone
in our facility that um uh related to uh
you know uh
a negative enforcement action related to
a facility for one of these service
providers instead they typically
um if there is an enforcement action
taken against them it's because these
individuals are working without a
license which is exactly what this bill
um Works to solve
um second most States already exempt
Niche Beauty services from licensing
requirements Mr Norris before uh explain
or shared with you some of those
statistics but I'm happy to go into
greater detail about about that and then
third house bill 644 is a job spell
reducing licensing barriers for aspiring
Beauty professionals
um is is an important part of keeping
workers in the state I recently learned
that New Hampshire over the last three
years has lost 200 licensed Beauty
professionals this bill would allow
individuals to be able to stay in the
state and to work and to use the skills
that they have to be able to to live
here and earn a living additionally this
bill is based off a proven reform that
has seen success in other states for
example after Minnesota pass its
freelance hair styling and makeup
license bill in 2020 there were about a
thousand Bridal and hair makeup artists
that were free to legitimately work
within the state when Arkansas passed a
similar bill in 2021 the first dry bar
which is a national franchise size of
blow dry bars opened opened in the state
additionally House Bill 644 mostly
benefits lower to Middle income women
who do not have the time money or
resources to attend traditional
cosmetology programs
finally this bill allows citizens from
across the state to benefit from the
wealth of new talent and Beauty
techniques that are currently difficult
to find
in conclusion I encourage the submittee
this committee to support House Bill 644
it's about aspiring Beauty entrepreneurs
have every opportunity to work and
Thrive here in New Hampshire thank you
for the opportunity to testify and and
I'm happy to answer any questions that
you may have
oh thank you are there any questions
representative Schmidt
so I'm intrigued by the use of the word
underground economy here this is in New
Hampshire talking about perhaps you
could talk to us a little bit more about
this the underground economy where this
is happening
of course I'm happy
people would be um Sophie who
lived here earlier today
hair braider in in New Hampshire but she
also would like to provide makeup
Artistry services and things like that
so as the law currently stands she is
not able to practice makeup Artistry and
get paid for it so she uses the loophole
that exists where she can provide makeup
artist services and not get paid for it
legally or she has to work underground
and not and technically provide those
Services illegally even though she's
doing the exact same thing I also wanted
to mention I think that there was a
question earlier about nursing homes
um and individuals related to hair
styling there's currently an exemption
in New Hampshire law that allows
individuals to do any cosmetology
service in nursing homes or in in homes
with someone who's immobile to be able
to to provide those Services now as as a
current exemption
thank you thank you other questions
okay thank you very much
and to close up of Representative power
thank you madam chair and honorable
committee members I'm truly
um glad to be here to be able to testify
on my bill unfortunately I was unable to
introduce the bill because I've been an
executive session in my committee
Municipal and County government since
this morning
so thankfully we ended and I was able to
catch the end of this hearing so for the
record I am representative Diane power I
represent the towns of Brookline Mason
and Greenville in Hillsborough County
District 36.
so
um
I'm gonna modify what I'm going to say
because it's not a bill introduction so
I would like to speak now on why this
bill is needed to to reiterate perhaps
what prior Witnesses testified
this bill addresses overburdensome
licensing requirements for individuals
who wish to provide any of the three
Niche Beauty services to clients here in
New Hampshire and those Niche Beauty
services are shampoo and blow dry
styling threading and makeup application
under current state statute individuals
who desire to provide these limited
Beauty services to clients they must
have a full cosmetology barbering and
Aesthetics license issued by the state
this creates unnecessary barriers to
employment and it inhibits
entrepreneurship for a number of reasons
Niche beauty salons are unlike
traditional full-service salons because
they offer
services that are their limited Services
they're very specific and these services
are inherently safe they do not use
involve the use of potentially dangerous
chemicals or tools
for example Threading salons offer
unwanted hair removal
using cotton thread and threading is
among the safest and most natural forms
of hair removal threading does not
involve the use of artificial chemicals
waxes or shop tools
also unlike traditional full service
salons dry dry blow dry bars offer safe
limited services including shampooing
conditioning blow drying and styling of
hair these specialty salons do not cut
hair they do not use chemicals and they
do not use dyes
blow dry bars are no different than Hair
Braiding salons in 2017 House Bill 82
exempting Hair Braiding from regulation
by the Board of barbering cosmetology
and a sex was signed into law in New
Hampshire
this bill before you seeks to do the
same for these three Niche Beauty
services
notably 2022 House Bill 1167 which I was
the Prime sponsor of last year it was a
niche Beauty bill
um
that bill as a result of it going
through that the process here it passed
the house and it went to the Senate
there was feedback because it included a
fourth Niche Beauty service and that was
eyelash extensions during hearings and
testimony there was a lot of concern
with that particular Niche Beauty
service and I listened to that feed book
back and this year when I refiled the
bill I removed eyelash extensions
um
from the bill moreover Niche beauty
salons are unlike traditional full
service salons because they offer
services that people perform every day
in their own homes
for these tasks the supplies the tools
shampoo blow dryers brushes Combs makeup
and cotton thread they that they're
readily available and they're purchased
and they are used by children and adults
every day what's more these Niche Beauty
Services involve skills that are
primarily learned at home outside of
cosmetology schools
currently in order to become a licensed
Beauty provider in the state of New
Hampshire a person must first invest
substantial time and money and they
oftentimes incur significant financial
debt in order to attend a cosmetology
program and then pass the State
Licensing exams in New Hampshire the
average cosmetology program cost over
nineteen thousand dollars and on top of
that a person must pay about two hundred
dollars in exam fees undoubtedly this
process is time consuming costly and
unjustifiable
also these occupational licensing
requirements disproportionately affect
economically disadvantaged individuals
the majority of which are women
existing laws prescribing these require
these requirements are an unnecessary
barrier to employment and it makes it
difficult for people who want to provide
Niche Beauty services to be able to earn
a living for themselves and their
families and as we heard in prior
testimony that sometimes and oftentimes
these individuals are forced to work
underground in addition these
unnecessary requirements they harm
consumers and they hurt our economy by
limiting the number of Niche Beauty
providers
so um
lastly how does this bill address the
issue at hand the solution that the bill
provides is straightforward first the
bill defines the limited scope of
practice for the for the following three
Niche Beauty Services shampooing and
blow dry styling threading and makeup
application and the bill exempts these
three Niche Beauty services from
Individual and facility license
requirements similar to the 27 2017 Hair
Braiding Bill and second this bill
repeals the requirement for individual
Booth licensure for independently
operated booths attached to or within a
licensed Salon or Barbershop this
provision has been included at the
request of the New Hampshire oplc
in conclusion
consumer demand for Niche Beauty
Services is quickly growing across the
country
overburdensome licensing requirements
hurts workers
customers and our economy
similar to The Hair Braiding bill in
2017 that is now a law this bill removes
the unnecessary red tape for individuals
seeking to work in the niche beauty
industry this bet Bill benefits workers
employers and consumers in the granite
state by creating greater access to
skilled labor and Beauty Services which
in turn boosts our economy and lastly
this bill upholds the current laws for
the practice of licensed barbering
cosmetology and Aesthetics professionals
offering the full scope of beauty
services that concludes my testimony
Madam chair
thank you are there any questions
representative Schmidt defer to
representative
she tied me but you looked in my
direction first you you drew the Short
Straw representative Schmidt asked your
question okay so uh thank you uh so
thank you for your testimony
representative and
um
although I I heard way too many
burdensoms here I found your burdensome
reference and it burdensome so uh but
um how many of these Niche salons are
there currently in New Hampshire
roughly I don't expect an exact count
my understanding is that there are two
um well there's two blow dry bars that
I'm aware of and then Ulta beauty shop
has
um a similar type Salon within their
store
however one must have a full cosmetology
license
I thought we Exempted some of this stuff
last year
the only thing we Exempted lot wasn't
last year was braiding the bill that we
passed last year died in the Senate and
did not that has been reference thank
you that that's good so there's only two
of these salons what is your estimate in
terms of how many there would be if we
passed this bill I thank you for the
question representative I did not do
data research to to to you know across
the state and call information as to how
many um of these salons as you asked
that my answer was based on what I just
know in in passing
and you're asking how
how many more businesses would open up
that is indeterminable we've heard so
much testimony that this seems like it's
everywhere Schmidt she's just said she
doesn't know well I I understand but but
the thing is there was only two somehow
they got right now they are required by
our laws to only employ licensed
cosmetologists if they were able to
employ without licenses would be cheaper
there might well I get that but the
thing is that we only have two and and
but there is a considerable amount of
testimony that suggests to me that this
is incredibly in demand and I'm just I'm
wondering so I'll I'll take another line
of questions may I respond
if you wish to okay so representative as
I recall the there was a prior witness
that that did speak to that specifically
that she is a researcher and
um with the institute for justice and
she did um I recall specify
that when other states in our country
Exempted
this Pro this licensure requirement that
there were a number of workers that
entered that field and additionally I I
don't recall that the number right I can
get it for you and there were businesses
that that did open in other states that
that did exactly what this bill is
looking to do okay I hear your testimony
so I can follow up because one of the
reasons that that I'm
taking this line of inquiry is that I'm
very concerned about the aspect of
hygiene I referenced it in my earlier
question to another witness and the
thing is that when you are doing this
threading thing you are in very close
proximity to people's eyes and to the
degree you have a an basically an
individual with relatively little
training this is we're given to
understand that these are the kinds of
things that people learn at home they do
it with their brothers and sisters
Mike I am asking my question
if if you if we're going to have a large
number of these institutions of you know
blowing up everywhere blow drying and so
forth but threading seems to I notice if
you look at watch television and you pay
any attention you see that women's
eyebrows are a major
a major aspect of women's facial makeup
just just look at eyebrows ladies and
gentlemen look at eyebrows on television
please represent okay so the point is if
the if we're going to see lots and lots
of these things with people with minimal
training working in close proximity to
people's eyes I want to go on record as
saying that I have a great concern with
regard to the potential
endangerment of our female population
who will be
I I want to know whether you have a
concern
about the possibility of eye infections
as a result of working with people's
eyes
representative thank you for bringing up
that point that is an important point
and on page two of the bill in Section 5
line 16 through 22 that is addressed
it says that the owner of a salon
shall verify the education training
skills and the competence of the person
who works in said salon and that the
owner also additionally shall be
responsible
shall be responsible for protecting the
health and safety of customers and the
persons who work in their own owner's
salon
so this includes the sanitation of the
facility and any equipment used in it
and so therefore I feel that your
concerns are adequately addressed in the
language of the Bill thank you thank you
are there any other questions
representative a bear
I promise to be brief thank you madam
thank you representative power for
coming in this afternoon to discuss this
my question is
on page
four
three oh page two sorry I was counting
the front of the bill
um page two where it says hire employee
at line one Higher employee or rent a
booth so this person would not be an
employee they would be a subcontractor
of the
um
and paragraph five on line 16 that the
owner of the salon so I see a little bit
of a challenge here but let me tell you
where I'm going with this
um the chemicals that are used in the
makeup shampooing or prep would that be
overseen by the owner of the salon and I
think that needs to be addressed
could you repeat the the question
I said I if I make she's asking if the
chemicals if any that are used for
shampooing
our rig are under the authority of the
person who holds the salon license
I would so
shampoo
I guess technically it's it's a chemical
but I don't see it as a dangerous
chemical yep could I clarify so
um my my point is makeup
um
so
I think we can let the subcommittee
worry about that you're on the
subcommittee
okay any other questions
okay thank you very much thank you is
there anybody else who wishes to testify
on House Bill 644
all right seeing none I will close the
hearing it will go to
um
the licensing subcommittee
we have the committee work will resume
next Wednesday
there are two subcommittees I'm
replacing you on the one that you're on
yeah we kick you out
he had to work I know he does
it happened it was just a joke it
happens to people
yes
but Madison's Matt will know yes he's
going to visit with you go to the to a
place
whatever okay that's fine I have no
problem no that's uh
she hasn't been involved
as yet
so I'm sure he'll be able to do at least
as good a job as she could
I I hope do you know